bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur Public Sénat la mission
commune d'information sur la filière
viande achève ses auditions présidé par
la sénatrice Bernardette bourzaille elle
est chargé d'établir un diagnostic des
difficultés rencontrées dans ce secteur
puis de faire une liste de propositions
car il s'agit de répondre aux attentes
des consommateurs et des différents
acteurs économiques dans le secteur de
la viande après l'affaire spangero cette
entreprise qui avait vendu de la viande
de cheval pour du bœuf cette affaire a
en effet mis en évidence les différents
et très sérieux dysfonctionnements sur
la traçabilité dans la chaîne de
production et de distribution des
produits alimentaires alors c'est dans
ce cadre précisément que le 26 juin la
mission commune d'information a entendu
plusieurs experts d'abord le directeur
de la sécurité animale Gilles Salva puis
deux conseiller auprès du ministère de
l'Agriculture de l'agroalimentaire et de
la forêt Jean-Guillaume bretenou et
Daniel Peron qui est lui plus
spécialement chargé des relations avec
les partenaires alors tout de suite sans
plus tarder directtion la salle
clémenenceau pour voir ces trois
auditions très bonne matinée à tous sur
Public Sénat nous avons le plaisir
d'accueillir pour cette audition
l'Agence nationale de sécurité sanitaire
de l'alimentation de l'environnement et
du travail plus connu sous le sigle
d'in avec Monsieur Gill Salva qui est
directeur de la santé
animale Monsieur Franck
Foures directeur adjoint du service de
l'évaluation des risques et Madame
Soline
chardign donc merci madamees et
Messieurs d'avoir répondu à cette
invitation de la mission
d'information sur la filière viande qui
a été créée au Sénat la demande du
groupe centriste UD di dont madame
gouachavan est membre et dont elle est
rapporteur je parle de
la mission bien
sûr nous vous avons adressé un
questionnaire concernant donc cette
affaire de
fraude sur la filière viande concernant
donc de la viande de cheval qui a été
étiqueté
bœuf ce questionnaire peut servir de
trame à notre intervention mais
peut-être madame gouachavan a-t-elle des
questions complémentaires à poser je lui
donne donne la parole merci madame la
Présidente merci Madame merci messieurs
de d'avoir accepté notre invitation et
de répondre à nos questions donc j'ai
j'ai petite chose complémentair aux
questions qui vous ont été fournies mais
bon tout d'abord pour resituer un peu
les choses donc l'émission de l'ANS
couvre l'évaluation des risques dans le
domaine de l'alimentation de
l'environnement et du travail en vue
d'éclairer les pouvoirs publics dans
leur politique sanitaire donc un rôle
très important placé sous la tutelle des
ministres chargés de la santé de
l'agriculture de l'environnement du
travail et de la consommation votre
agence donc met en œuvre une exper une
expertise scientifique indépendante et
pluraliste elle contribue principalement
à assurer la sécurité sanitaire humaine
dans le domaine de l'alimentation
notamment ce qui nous intéresse très
particulièrement aujourd'hui votre
agence assure notamment la veille
sanitaire en une pharmacovigilance des
médicaments vétérinaires une
épidémiosurveillance en santé animal
ainsi qu'un observatoire sur les résidus
de pesticides euh autant de sujets que
nous avons peu abordés lors de des
précédentes auditions alors euh vous
pouvez bien sûr nous parler de vos
missions et répondre aux questions qui
sont qui vous ont été fourni
euh mais concernant plus
particulièrement la pharmacovigilance
certains scientifiques ont dénoncé les
dangers pour la santé humaine de
certains médicaments ou de certains
cocktail de
médicaments dont on retrouve la trace
dans les viandes de certaines espèces d'
animales alors peut-être pouvez-vous
nous en parler alors j'espère pour nous
rassurer pas pour nous nous affoler ou
ou alors peut-être avez-vous une
sonnette d'alarme à tirer je ne sais pas
je vous laisse juge et en tout cas
pouvez-vous aussi nous parler des
résidus de pesticides dans les viandes
alors questions subsidiaires aux
questions qui vous ont été fournies
merci messieurs et Madame alors lque
vous prenez la parole vous voulez bien
voilà vous avez le voilà bien mettre
mentendez là effectivement le micro euh
alors sur les je j'ouvre mon ordinateur
parce que j'ai quelques résultats
justement sur les notamment sur les
résidus de médicamen euh pour lesquels
il y a un plan de contrôle européen dans
le cadre d'une d'une directive
européenne de 1980 pardon pour lequel il
y a une un plan de contrôle européen
dans le cadre d'une directive européenne
de 1996 et en fait alors c'est pas l'an
16 qui est chargé de mettre en œuvre
cette directive c'est le ministère de
l'Agriculture qui qui digilante un plan
de contrôle tous les ans et donc ça fait
je vais vous donner quelques chiffres
mais plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'échantillons qui sont tous les ans en
fait analysés pour un certain nombre de
médicaments V de résidus de médicaments
vétérinaires et également de de résidus
de de
produits contaminant de l'environnement
on va dire alors j'ai surtout des
chiffres pour les médicaments
vétérinaires parce que en tant que
directeur de la santé animale c'est plus
mon domaine mais
euh pour pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée he sur les le nombre d'analyses
qui sont
faites j'ai j'ai les résultats pour 2010
et je pourrais vous les faire parvenir
éventuellement si vous voulez les les
résultats de ces ces plans y compris les
résultats mais c'est un peu plus de
20000 analyses sur les
beauovins 12000 presque 12500 à peu près
chez les porsins 2600 chez les ovins et
caprins 500 chez les chevau 8500 chez
les volailles et ainsi de suite en fait
bon c'est décliné en fonction de la de
la production et c'est un pourcentage de
la production en fait qui est qui est
analysé pour un certain nombre de
médicaments qui ont soit qui sont
interdits comme le chlorenhénicol par
exemple qui est interdit depuis 25 ans à
peu près dans les dans les productions
animales
et alors on peut en trouver oui
effectivement on peut en trouver mais
enfin c'est vraiment on recherche des
des des traces et il peut enfin on a vu
des cas notamment alors pas en France
mais au Brésil notamment on a retrouvé
du chloren
phénicle des quantités non
négligeables dans des élevages où les
les réserves c'est un médicament qui é
administré par l'eau et il y avait de
l'entartrage dans les canalisations
d'eau et il y a eu des des relargages en
fait de de tartrre qui ont
ponctuellement donné des résidus c'est
l'explication qu'en ont donné les
autorités brésiliennes euh il y a un
certain nombre de pays dans le monde
dans lequel ce pour lequel ce médicament
est pas est pas interdit donc voilà les
mystères du calcaire les mystères du
calcaire enfin ou des ou des dépôts dans
les ceci dit il y a effectivement des
dépôts dans les circuits d'approfement
mais voilà pour vous donner une idée de
de du nombre d'analyses qui sont
réalisées euh oui c'est considérable
alors c'est considérable alors parmi les
missions que vous avez cité de l'agence
je rajouterai une mission de recherche
et de référence qui est peut-être un peu
moins connu mais qui occupe à peu près
la moitié de nos effectifs on est on a
11 laboratoires qui sont répartis sur 18
sites sur le territoire national y
compris département d'outremer puisqu'on
a un site à la Réunion qui travaille sur
la santé animale la sécurité sanitaire
des aliments et la santé des végétaux et
et dans ces laboratoires en fait on fait
des recherches on est laboratoire de
référence pour une soixantaine de de
références qui sont qui sont
obligatoires dans le cadre de la
réglementation européenne de maladie et
de et ou contaminants zoonotique par
exemple les salmonnelles les
campilobactères les choses comme ça et
dans ces laboratoires donc on met au
point des méthodes de détection plus
rapide plus fiable plus sensible des des
des pathogènes éventuellement des
résidus de de médicamen vétérinaire ça
ça se fait à fougère et on fait aussi de
la recherche pour essayer de comprendre
comment circulent ces agents pathogènes
enfin c'est toute notre mission
d'épidémiosurveillance aussi que que
vous avez cité dans votre dans votre
préambule et donc c'est laboratoire
recherche qui représente à peu près 700
personnes au sein de l'agence euh
produisent des comme tous les
laboratoires de recherche linra du CNRS
des publications scientifique mais aussi
de façon plus appliquée des méthodes qui
sont ensuite transmises transférées aux
laboratoires
départementaux euh de façon à ce qu'il
se les approprie et qu'ell puisse servir
ensuite au au planans de surveillance et
notamment dans ce cadre-là ce qui ce qui
nous importe pour l'avenir alors ce
qu'on sait faire actuellement c'est
doser en terme de chimie un certain
nombre de molécules dont on connaît
l'existence et qu'on va les rechercher
spécifiquement et ce qu'on cherche à
faire de plus en plus c'est être capable
de doser des choses qu'on ne connaît pas
c'est-à-dire d'avoir des méthodes
multi-analyse qui simultanément vont
doser une centaine de contaminants et en
bon c'est souvent de la spectrométrie de
masse qu'on utilise et en analysant les
spectres en fait les pics de en
spectrométrie de masse ça nous permet de
détecter un certain nombre de substances
qui qui ne devrait pas se trouver
éventuellement dans les aliments alors
dans les 5 à 10 ans on pense avoir des
méthodes comme ça qui à partir de d'un
d'un échantillon vont pouvoir sortir
l'ensemble de ce qu'on peut trouver
qu'on ne devrait pas trouver dans cet
échantillon et même chose pour les
pathogènes où on a on va développer je
pense dans les 5 à 10 ans qui viennent
des techniques qu'on appelle de
séquençage profond où on va séquencer
tout ce qui se trouve dans l'échantillon
c'està-dire aussi bien l'ADN de l'espèce
animale ça nous intéresse dans le cas de
fraude mais euh aussi l'ADN des virus
des bactéries des parasites qui se
trouvent dans cet échantillon et pour
peu qu'on sache faire le traitement
biomathématique de tout ça on sera
capable assez vite de de donner le le la
carte d'identité de ce qu'on appelle le
le le microbiome on va dire de d'un
aliment ou d'une d'un d'un prélèvement
quelconque voilà pour les orientations
un peu stratégiques de nos recherches
pour améliorer les techniques de
détection
peut-être puis-je réagir sur l'autre
versant de de la question qui est la
partie produit phytosanitaire puisque
c'était une de vos préoccupations alors
très très clairement donc aujourd'hui
donc c'est rarement on a rarement come
trit la filière viande on a en général
l'alimentation de manière générale et
les dangers microbiologiqu chimique et
les bénéfices et risques nutritionnels
de l'autre et donc sur la partie chimie
donc qu'on mène régulièrement c'est des
études qu'on appelle des études de
l'alimentation totale les eat dans notre
jargon on en est à la à la deuxème qui
sont qui sont qui a été qui a été rendu
en 2011 donc ces études d'alimentation
totale c'est des des outils qui sont
très très utiles parce qu'il s'agit en
fait de reconstituer le panier d'un
Français sur la base d'enquête de
consommation représentative de qu'est-ce
que consomme un Français dans dans une
année et d'aller faire une donc un un
échantillonnage en fait de tous les
produits de toutes les marques qui sont
consommées par des Français et après
d'aller mener une grosse campagne
d'analyse puisquen fait il s'agit de
rechercher 450 substances dans plus de
20000 échantillons donc c'est quand même
des des grosses opérations et ce qui
nous permet de conclure en fait sur
l'exposition des Français un certain
nombre de de alors contaminants
chimiques mais aussi ça peut être des
des le plomb les métaux et cetera et
évidemment donc sur sur le AT1 cont tenu
des des des des sommes qui étaient
disponible il n'y avait pas les produits
phytosanitaires et c'était un pour nous
un un problème et donc on a souhaité
l'intégrer dans le dans le AT2 donc vous
pourrez trouver on pourra vous fournir
effectivement à la fois la vie et puis
les les rapports correspondant à ça il
se trouve que globalement sur la partie
viande et Abas c'est un assez faible
contributeur à l'exposition chimique des
Français pour la plupart des des des
contaminants chimiques he contrairement
à au poissons par exemple et au
crustacés qui contenu à la fois de des
chaînes trophiques et cetera et de de la
consommation sont plus sont plus
contributeur donc on pourra vous faire
parvenir parvenir ça alors juste à
signaler donc c'est important que que
Gill en ait parlé de dans dans les choix
qu'on a dû faire dans le AT2
effectivement on a exclu les médicaments
vétérinaires pour la simple raison que
eux étaient réglementés en terme de
nombre d'analyse par la Communauté
européenne qui avait déjà un gros pool
d'analyse qui était fait avec quand même
de faibles résultats positifs et donc
dans les arbitrages budgétaires qui qui
ont été faits pour pouvoir inclure les
produits phytosanitaires il n'y avait
pas euh les les médicaments vétérinaires
c'était un on le regrette et on essaie
de travailler sur des méthodes qui nous
permettraient d'intégrer les résultats
de tous ces de de de tous ces plans de
surveillance et de contrôle des méthodes
statistiques pour les interpréter dans
le cadre de des EAT de manière à sans
trop de dépenses publiques arriver à
pouvoir conclure sur l'exposition des
Français à ces à ces médicaments
vétérinaires globalement vous pensez
quand même globalement vous pensez quand
même que
l'utilisation si on prend le cas des
antibiotiques puisqu'il y a quand même
une campagne très très importante
sur l'utilisation des antibiotiques par
rapport aux animaux vous pensez que ça
diminue vous pensez que c'est efficasse
c'est Monsieur antibiorésistance
répondre à ma
gauche pour les antibiotiques enfin ce
qu'on peut dire par rapport au résidu
d'antibiotique on on peut dire que le
risque est extrêmement faible et que le
problème des l'utilisation des
antibiotiques dans les filières animales
se situe pas sur le plan des résidus
dans les viandes parce que les temps
d'attente sont respectés et temps
d'attente étant respecté on est en
dessous de la limite maximale de résidus
assez systématiquement bon il y a
évidemment quelques cas positifs hein
mais ça reste vraiment un épiphénomène
et en tout cas pas un problème de santé
publique extrêmement grave ce qui nous
préoccupe dans l'utilisation des
antibiotiques c'est plutôt la la
génération de la sélection de bactéries
résistantes chez les animaux lesquelles
bactéries résistantes vont servir de
porteur de gène en fait de résistance
vers l'homme soit par par le contact
direct avec ces animaux c'est le cas
pour les animaux domestiques c'est le
cas pour les animaux de Rand pour le
l'éleveur le vétérinaire ou le
technicien d'élevage et soit par la
chaîne alimentaire éventuellement
parceque on sait que toutes les
bactéries ne sont pas détruites par la
cuisson et on peut on peut aussi avoir
des des des contaminations croisées
lorsqu'on manipule des des produits
animaux ou des produits végétaux sur
lequels on a eu
une un engrais un engrais organique qui
peuvent être contaminés par des des
bactéries animales donc on s'intéresse à
la circulation entre les différents
compartiments de la chaîne alimentaire
de ces gènes d'antibiorésistance et y
compris dans l'environnement où on a un
vecteur qui peut transférer ses gênnes
par l'eau même si on boit de l'eau
potable en France est
traité mais aussi par l'arrosage l'eau
d'arrosage des légumes par les les les
engrais organiques et cetera donc ça
c'est notre préoccupation majeure et ce
qu'on peut dire enfin on a alerté depuis
3 4 ans donc on 3 ans on fait des tous
les ans une une réunion annuelle dans
lesquelle on invite toutes nos parties
prenantes aussi bien les les
professionnels de de l'élevage que les
organisations de consommateurs que les
les nos élus et donc on fait cette
réunion généralement au mois de novembre
cette année sera probablement au mois
d'octobre où on rend nos résultats donc
on a deux réseaux un réseau qui
surveille la résistance des bactéries
pathogènes de l'animal
l'antibiorésistance de ces bactéries
pathogènes et sur lequel on analyse
24000 résultats d'antibiogramm par an à
peu près entre entre 20 et 25000 et puis
un réseau qui surveille la consommation
des antibiotiques et en comparant les
deux ben on voit si effectivement des
augmentations de consommation sont à
l'origine d'augmentation de résistance
on a il y a 4 ans commencé à voir des
augmentations qu'on a jugé critique de
de résistance à certains antibiotiques
critiques justement notamment les
fluokinolon et les céphalosporines de 3e
génération alors pourquoi sont-ils
critiques bien parce ce sont des
antibiotiques qui sont utilisés chez
l'homme en avant-dernière intention
avant alors la dernière intention c'est
ce qu'on appelle les carbapénem ce sont
des antibiotiques qui sont utilisés
uniquement à l'hôpital et en
injection donc qui ne sont absolument
pas utilisés en médecine
vétérinaire et donc avant ça pour des
cas notamment d'infection noocomiale
mais on les utilise aussi en en médecine
de ville et ça ça fait partie des
problèmes d'antibiorésistance aussi C
céphalosporine de 3e génération sont
utilisé pour soigner quelques maladies
graves à l'hôpital et la présence de
gènees de résistance en grande quantité
chez les animaux nous a fortement
préoccupé parce que on pensait que le
risque était non négligeable de voir
émerger des résistances chez l'homme qui
étaaiit lié à des pratiques dans les
dans les élevages on en a
alerté nos partenaires des des filières
des organisations de consommateurs et
cetera et bon il se trouve queil y a
avant même le plan écoantibiot qui a été
euh mis en place par le Ministère de
l'Agriculture l'an dernier euh notamment
la filière porcine par exemple a fait un
moratoire sur l'utilisation de ces
antibiotiques critiques notamment parce
qu'ils étaient utilisés dans les phases
d'élevage critique aussi c'est-à-dire le
le sevrage en fait hein où on fait
passer l'animal d'une alimentation
lactée à une alimentation solide où il y
a des déséquilibres digestifs qui se
mettent en place et et plutôt que
d'utiliser des antibiotiques pour pour
essayer de réguler ces équilibres
digestifs euh bah les éleveurs ont
commencé a se préoccuper d'utiliser des
bonnes méthodes d'élevage une
alimentation mieux équilibrée pour
assurer cette transition un peu à
l'image de ce qui se fait chez l'homme
hein vous savez que le sevrage c'est une
établee critique aussi et que il y a un
certain nombre de précautions à prendre
euh même si enfin toute chose étant
égale par ailleurs les conditions sont
pas les mêmes mais et ça fait quand même
que par exemple dans ces phases
critiques de de postsevrage les
céphalosporines ont diminué en une année
de 60 % dans leur utilisation donc ça
enfin je dirais que à la fois bon c'est
pas simplement l'an qui est qui est
responsable de ce grand mouvement sur
l'antibiorésistance on y participe nous
on alerte on essaie de conseiller aussi
de de dire orientez-vous vers d'autres
méthodes d'élevage plus plus
respectueuses de de l'animal de densité
de moins de mélange d'animaux venant de
M différentes pour éviter de mélanger
les microbismes exactement et euh et et
tout ça fait que on a une très bonne
prise de conscience des filières qui
aboutit actuellement on commence à voir
les effets alors on a vu d'abord les
effets sur la diminution des
consommations et en décalage de 1 an ou
2 ans euh on commence à voir les effets
sur la diminution des résistances alors
pourquoi il y a un décalage ben parce
que les bactéries elles peuvent résister
dans l'environnement elles ont un un
l'antibiorésistance a un coûp biologique
qui est différent d'une bactérie à
l'autre donc certaines résistent mieux
dans l'environnement quand elles sont
résistant d'autres moins bien plutôt
moins bien en général d'ailleurs mais
tout ça fait que il y a souvent un
décalage en fait entre l'arrêt d'une
molécule ou la diminution de son
utilisation et la la réelle diminution
du nombre de de bactéries porteuses de
gèes de
résistance donc voilà ce qu'on fait en
plus des recherches qu'on fait sur ces
circulations de de gènes dans
l'environnement et aussi la détection de
nouveaux gènes ce qui fait partie de
notre de notre trava obigé de partir
mais j'ai une j'ai une question par
rapport quand même par exemple les
différents secteurs naturellement
de que nos compatri tu utilise volaille
port veau et cetera bovin est-ce qu'il y
a surtout une une de ces productions qui
qui qui semblerait plus
sensible je salue avec satisfaction l ce
que vous venez nous dire par rapport à à
ces dossiers qui ont beaucoup interpellé
les consommateurs mais aussi même les
les éleveurs c'est vrai que et je trouve
que ça va dans le bon sens d'ailleurs si
on voit aujourd'hui les vétérinaires ils
font très très attention quand même
l'animal est identifié on va cherchait
du médicament on sait à quel animal la
poologie et puis en même temps je crois
que les vétérinaire pour beaucoup disent
on utilise antibiotiques qu'on vraiment
peut pas utiliser autre chose je crois
quand même qu'il y a eu alors que il y a
20 ans o disons c'était systématiquement
all cétaitit antibiotique donc ça va ça
va dans le bon sens alors est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est plutôt sur est-ce
que serait sur les Pors sur les
volailles c'est les beauins ou peut-être
je pense pas les auins parce qu'ils sont
tellement en plein
air
toujours pas toujours alors en fait il
il y avait chaque filière avait ses
propres problèmes et ses propres
problèmes de phase physiologique un peu
difficile à passer bon en porort c'est
plutôt le postsevrage en volaille c'est
après 8 jours on va dire euh et ça
conduisait d'ailleurs les les les
accouverurs à à injecter des
antibiotiques par prévention sur le
poussin de un jour c'est typiquement le
genre de pratique sur lesquel on a
alerté beaucoup et sur lesquel la
diminution de de ces pratiques et est
vraiment notoire notable euh sur le veau
de boucherie le problème est c'est un
très jeune animal qu'on va réaloter avec
des animaux qui viennent d'élevage
différents donc c'est des animaux qui
ont des troubles digestifs du du du
jeune âge assez fréquant le lapin aussi
avait étit réputé très consommateur
c'était la filière au au nombre au poids
produit qui qui consommait le plus
d'antibiotiques et c'est une des
premières qui a réagi c'est une des
premières qui a réagi avec un plan de
démédication de la filière lapin qui lui
aussi porte très largement ses fruits
depuis ça fait 2 ans et 2 ans et demi
qu'il est en place et et c'est enfin je
dirais que il y avait des problèmes dans
toutes les filières on va dire hein mais
que tout ont pris avec plus ou moins un
delta d'un an à peu près les les mesures
qui s'imposaient parce que tout ont
senti à la fois le risque y compris pour
les éleveurs hein d'être porteur de on a
vu en Hollande des éleveurs porteurs de
stapilococus oréus résistant à la
méticyine qui venaient de leur cochon et
ça conduisait les les autorité sanitaire
hollandaise à isoler les éleveurs de
porortc dans les quand ils arrivaient à
l'hôpital alors il se trouve qu'on a
pour une raison qu'on comprend pas
complètement on avait pas ce sarme
particulier en France on très peu mais
mais j'ai pas toutes les explications à
ça probablement que les méthodes
d'élevage sont un petit peu différentes
et et d'utilisation
des oui peut-être et après peut-être que
l'utilisation des antibiotiques se
faisait pas la même période après ils
ont peut-être eu un clone qui s'est
implanté plus facilement nous on a le
même mais sensible aux antibiotiques
donc c'est un coup de chance pourvu que
ça dure justement et pour que ça dure
pour que ça dure il faut mettre en place
des pratiques raisonné raisonné parce
que quand même on a besoin des
antibiotiques dans les filières animales
pour soigner les animaux malades et ça
c'est euh c'est c'est pas automatique
voilà et c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
il faut être capable de de il faut être
capable de soigner un animal malade et
de le soulager c'est important qu'on
qu'on garde un arsenal thérapeutique et
efficace et et durable par rapport aussi
à à la médecine
humaine
voulez-vous compléter monsieur forestut
pas compléter sur cette question là je
pense que Gill a fait un tour assez
complet d'horizon peut-être rebondir sur
sur une ou deux questions que vous nous
avez posé qu'on peux pas aborder
notamment sur donc l'interface vous avez
très bien situé le le rôle de l'ANS en
terme d'évaluation des risque G a
replacé aussi la partie laboratoire
activité de surveillance et recherche
euh donc on parle souvent de cette
séparation entre l'évaluation et la
gestion des risques mais évidemment il y
a quand même des interfaces et notamment
une des interfaces importantes et
intéressantes c'est c'est qu'on est on
est soumis enfin dans le cadre de
l'évaluation des risques on nous soumet
tutelle nous soumett tous les textes Tex
importants qui vont être qui vont être
votés soit de manière quand le texte est
prêt à être à être proposé un arrêté
ministériel ou autre mais souvent plus
en amont comme la plupart de ces textes
dans ce domaine sont des textes
communautaires la Commission européenne
fait des feuilles de route où elle donne
un peu les les les la direction qu'elle
veut prendre en matière de
réglementation et c'est souvent la base
pour pour le les tutelles de pour nous
saisir donc un des des bons exemples en
la mati
en la matière me semble-t-il c'est le
c'est les feuilles de route sur les les
encéphalopathies spongiformes
transmissibles puis que c'est aussi une
des questions que vous nous avez posé
puisqueeffectivement donc on a été saisi
par nos tutelles sur sur cette question
dès que la feuille la enfin la première
feuille de route et puis la deuxième
feuille de route et donc on a produit
aujourd'hui six avis he sur cette
question on a on a séparé les différents
champs parce que ils sont assez large
sur cette question qui est quand même
une grosse question donc à la fois sur
les protéines animales transformées mais
la surveillance de l'ESB à l'écarissage
les politiques de sélection génétique
des petits ruminants les tests à
l'abattoire et puis les MRSS des des
petits ruminants donc si on reprend
l'exemple des protéines animales
transformées qui me paraît relativement
intéressant parce qu'il voit un peu quel
est quel est le où commence et où
s'arrête le le rôle d'interface de
l'aness en matière de politique de
contrôle donc globalement les les les
les experts de l'incess après avoir
regardé un peu quel était le rôle de la
barrière d'espèce dans l'arrêt possible
de de la transmission de de l'agent de
la enfin de de l'ESB on on conclut que
bon du fait de de cette barrière
d'espèce qui est effective mais qui
n'est pas une barrière complète et
totale il considérait que dans les
conditions qui étaient proposées dans
les conditions strictes qui étaient
proposé
par par le la Commission européenne
c'est-à-dire de ne pas remettre dans une
espèce des protéines animal transformé
de la même espèce on pouvait considérer
sur la base des connaissances actuelles
que le risque était négligeable mais ce
cela voulait dire à condition qu'on
respecte complètement strictement cette
interdiction et donc les experts ont
souhaité que on puisse documenter en
France quelles étaient les conditions
qui permettaient ce respect strict euh
de de de de ces conditions donc
notamment ils ont demandé donc un
rapport de au cgaer donc le Conseil
Général de l'alimentation de
l'agriculture et des espaces ruraux de
manière à ce qu'on leur fasse un état
des lieux de la spécialisation des
filières et de leur organisation en
France pour savoir effectivement est-ce
qu'on pouvait considérer qu'il y avait
une spécialisation suffisante pour
garantir cette étanchéité en fait entre
les filières et puis deuxièmement euh
ils ont ben reçu les différences
scientifiques pour voir quels étaient
les protocoles de test qui existaient
qui sur la la la la la particularité des
farines animales c'est qu'elles sont
chauffées très fortement que du coup les
l'ADN est dégradé et que du coup il est
difficile de faire le diagnostic
d'espèces une fois qu'on a qu'on a qu'on
a mis ce procédé en place et du coup
vérifier qu'on puisse effectivement
contrôler une fois une fois le
dispositif adopté son respect et là en
l'occurrence les les les conditions
n'étaient pas réunies et c'est pour ça
que l'an s'est prononcé défavorablement
du fait des conditions non réunies donc
voilà je pense que ce cet élément il est
assez intéressant parce que il montre un
peu l'interface qui peut y avoir avec la
gestion sachant que pour autant on on ne
va jamais jusqu'à dire voilà le on ver
ie que les conditions soient réunies
pour que le contrôle soit possible après
on ne passe jamais le cran supérieur qui
est de dire voilà quel type de contrôle
il faudrait à quel rythme pour garantir
les choses c'est dont on considère qu'
est vraiment proprement du du rôle de la
gestion il y a que pour les plans de
surveillance et planans de contrôle
c'est-à-dire le nombre d'analyse qu'il
faudrait faire sur quel type de
contaminant par exemple oou là
effectivement comme on est vraiment dans
le domaine analytiqueù on a beaucoup
beaucoup de
compéten on peut aller jusqu'à dire quel
est le le nombre de contrôles
intéressant et cetera donc voilà voilà
ça ça me permet de de traiter presque de
questions en une à la fois le fait que
comment on gère un peu cette interface
entre entre le la gestion et
l'évaluation des risques mais aussi donc
ce qui a été fait et ce qui peut être
fait en terme de d'allègement des des
mesures en matière de d'encéphalopathie
spangiforme transmissible sachant
qu'aujourd'hui donc il y a six avis qui
sont qui sont
rendusin que on peut vous transmettre
donc il font un peu le point sur
aujourd'hui quelles sont les
possibilités d'allègement et il y en a
un qui est en cours qui doit paraître
dans l'été sur les MRSS de petit
ruminant en fait puisque bon sur la
partie bovin on est on est sur sur le
même pas que que l'Europe sur la partie
petit ruminant il y a des des sument
histoire des cervelles par exemple qu'on
peut importer de pays voisins très très
proches pour des animaux des in qui ont
plus de 6 mois alors que chez nous on
peut pas commercialiser des cervelles
qui ont moins de 6 mois donc ça nous a
été souvent dit c'est exemple criant on
dira qui est souvent repris mais voilà
faut-il nivler un peu pas forcément par
le bas mais nivel un peu au niveau de
l'Europe tout à il y a une autre
question d'ailleurs que je pose en
complément la démédulation qui nous a
été également signalé au moment de
l'abattage l'aspiration de la moelle
épinière qui estbl enfin qui reste
obligatoire en France et qui ne l'est
plus depuis le 1er janvier en Europe oui
tout à fait donc on a été on a été
ressaisi hein sur cette question là
récemment on doit rendre un avis donc je
peux pas dévoiler l'avis des experts sur
la
question malheureusement mais en fait le
posa la question nous oui oui bien sûr
euh donc typiquement effectivement il il
y a de manière générale sur C sur ces
est le l'objet de d'harmoniser la
réglementation parce que c'est vrai
qu'en terme de de
circulation je pense que il y a vraiment
il y a vraiment un intérêt à ce que à ce
que les réglementation soit harmonisée
dans l'Union européenne après on est
nous ce qu'on essaie de fournir c'est à
nos autorités de tutelle les arguments
qui sont ceux de nos experts pour aller
vers soit un retour à compte tenu de la
situation épidémiologique française ou
communautaire un retour vers la la
position communautaire soit essayer de
d'avoir de manière générale une position
plus strict au niveau communautaire ça
ça peut être dans les deux sens voà oui
ça peut être dans les deux sens enfin je
pense qu'en effet il ne faut pas baisser
la garde mais il ne faut pas que la
France s'autopénalise et pénalise
elle-même ses ses producteurs et et ces
filières viande alors après nous ce
qu'on dit toujours c'est que voilà on
fait une évaluation scientifique sans
prendre en compte les aspects
économiques hein c'est très clair pour
nos experts il y a des fois ils nous
disent enfin il en dit très clairement
dans l'avis sur les les tests l'arrêt
des tests à l'abattoir il considèrent
que d'un point de vue sanitaire même si
on arrête qu'une seule carcasse en
faisant un million et demi de test et
que le risque est est faible c'est
toujours un plus après ils admettent que
d'un point de vue socio-économique c'est
les tutelles sont sont informés de de de
la chose et peuvent
voilà savoir quel est le niveau de
risque acceptable voilà et que voilà ils
font ils essayent de faire la part des
choses sur sur le ce qui est de l'ordre
des experts qui n'est pas de
d'intérioriser des questions économiques
mais de faire la le bilan sur qu'est-ce
qu'on sait que ce que la science sait
pour laisser au tutelle le choix en
fonction de de ces éléments là de
décider de de prendre de pas prendre en
compte la vie des experts et de fixer
son niveau de sécurité c'est pour ça
qu'il peut y avoir des distensions entre
les pays avec des pays qui ont choisi
des niveaux de sécurité un tout petit
peu plus élevés d'autres un peu moins il
il y a l'équivalent de l'anesse j'ose
espérer dans tous les pays de l'Union
européenne j'ose espérer vous allez me
répondre et et y a-t-il y a-t-il des
échanges des
échanges scientifiques pour pas dire
socio économique mais au moins
scientifique vous devez vous retrouver
sur la science qui est qui est
cartésienne peut dire ce qu' ce qu'on
peut dire c'est qu'il y a pas de il y a
pas d'agence de sécurité sanitaire dans
tous les pays européens il y en a dans
tous les grands pays européens on dire
je connaissais la réponse mais je
voulais ce soit dit je je dirait enfin
dans dans le dans l'ex europeope des 15
en fait hein il il y a des agences de
sécurité sanitaire en ce qui concerne
nos nos
relations on a une direction des
affaires internationales et européennes
au sein de l'ANS qui est très active
pour pour signer un certain nombre
d'accords moi-même hier j'étais à
Copenhague pour un colloque d'une
association qui s'appelle medvetnet et
qui est issu d'un d'un réseau
d'excellence européen que nous avions
créé et dirigé pendant 5 ans donc céit
un appel d'offre européen dans les dans
les programmes du du 7e du 6e Programme
Cadre et qui était destiné à à mettre de
l'argent pour créer de l'animation
scientifique entre des des instituts de
recherche et nous donc medvetnet c'est
un institut qui s'est créé un institut
virtuel qui s'est créé autour des
honoses alimentaires notamment des
honoses en général alimentaires en
particulier et donc on avait notre
colocque annuel hier à Copenhague et
c'est une communauté scientifique on
était 15 au départ on doit être 17
maintenant de d'institut de de recherche
et d'agence de sécurité sanitaire qui
travaille à la fois sur le côté humain
et le côté animal d'où met vetnet et et
et qui qui fait de la recherche
collaborative on a on était au à la
Danish technical University à Copenhague
et on vient de signer on va encadrer en
commun un doctorant qui va venir un an
et demi chez nous un an et demi
en au Danemark bon là sur un sujet sur
l'hyéria monostogenèse qui est un qui
est un contaminant de l'alimentation de
plus en plus rare qu'on a bien réussi à
à maîtriser depuis une trentaine
d'années mais voilà on a énormément de
collaboration on a notre groupe qui
s'appelle le club 5 avec les Allemands
les Danois les Suédois les Anglais et
nous euh qui est aussi très actif qui
cofinance des programmes de recherche
pour pour essayer de promouvoir des
collaborations entre nos équipes enfin
essayer on y arrive très bien puis enfin
on répond aussi à beaucoup d'appels
d'offre de de l'Union européenne ne
serait-ce que depuis le début de l'année
on doit avoir trois nouveaux programmes
européens qui ont été accepté dans le
cadre du 7e Programme Cadre et on espère
être aussi performant dans le cadre
d'horizon 2020 le prochain programme
cadre ça fait partie de notre métier de
chercheur en fait d'aller de faire de la
recherche collaborative et alors ça
c'est pour la recherche après en terme
d'évaluation des risques on a aussi pas
mal d'échanges dans dans le domaine par
exemple sur la crise au 104 H4 en
Allemagne les les morceaux d'ADN qui ont
servi à identifier le 104 H4 en
Allemagne ont été produits dans notre
laboratoire de Maison Alfort parce que
nos deux agences le BFR et l'ANS
collaborent beaucoup se connaissaient
bien et nous il se trouve que dans notre
banque de gène on avait ce gène de ha
104 ce qui a permis aux Allemands ce qui
nous a permis de transférer la méthodo à
une petite société de bretonne je viens
de Bretagne ça m'a fait plaisir qui a
mis au point le kit en 10 jours à peu
près et qui a transférer ce kit de
détection aux Allemands ce qui a permis
aux Allemands de gagner beaucoup de
temps dans la dans dans la détection de
de ce nouveau
pathogène oui et au concom de survivre
exactement et et je dois dire que
accessoirement ça nous a permis aussi
gagner beaucoup de temps quand on a eu
10k à Bordeaux avec le même lot de
graine parce qu'on avait déjà la méthode
et que donc voilà enfin cette
collaboration européenne elle est
effectivement très importante on a aussi
une collaboration avec l'fsa on a euh un
certain nombre de nos experts qui sont
dans des dans les panels permanents de
l'fsa au moins deux en santé animale euh
on a un certain nombre d'experts de nos
laboratoires qui vont participer à des
groupes de travail de l'autorité
européenne et puis on participe à la
gouvernance de l'autorité européenne à
travers des des des forums de
coordination moi-même je participe au
groupe un groupe qui s'appelle animal
heal and welfare donc qui travaille sur
les santé animal et bien-être des
animaux on essaie de là c'est des
groupes interagences en fait coordonnés
par l'fsa qui enfin qui qui partagent
sur les évaluations des risques qu'on a
dans nos programmes à venir de façon à
ce qu'on ne duplique pas
systématiquement au niveau européen qui
est fait enfin que nous par exemple on
ne duplique pas ce que l'fsa fait ou
qu'on réponde pas exactement aux mêmes
questions et inversement que l'fsa ne
répondent pas à des questions auxquelles
on a déjà répondu et pour lesquelles ce
serait une simple duplication c'est pas
toujours le cas parce que le problème au
niveau européen peut être différent du
problème au niveau français parfois
enfin ne serait-ce que la situation
épidémiologique mais on essaie de
coordonner tout ça oui même si
certainement des améliorations à
apporter ça c'est c'est quelque chose
qui se met en place depuis que l'fsa
existe
lentement au départ ça c'est accéléré
depuis 4 ou 5
ans bien alors dernière question qu'on
vous avait posé sur les travaux sur les
risques conduisez-vous les travaux sur
les risques de déséquilibre
nutritionnel lié à la sur ou à la
sconsommation de viande et quels sont
les apports essentiels en nutriment
résultant de la consommation de viande
alors on a effectivement tout un une
unité qui travaille sur les bénéfices
risque nutritionnel de manière générale
dans dans l'alimentation donc qui a
participé vraiment très activement en
2001 quand il s'est agit de de
construire les premiers repères de
consommation pour les populations la
population générale et puis les
différentes types de population dans le
cadre du du Programme National Nutrition
Santé donc par contre ça ça remonte
quand même 2001 en terme scientifique il
y a beaucoup d'évolution depuis donc on
a été ressaisi l'an dernier enfin en
avril dernier euh pour réactualiser donc
c'est un énorme travail puisque ça veut
dire sur tous les nutriments et tous les
groupes d'aliments refaire toute la
biblio des associations potentiel avec
des pathologies des bénéfices pour
mettre mettre tout ça à jour et pouvoir
réviser un peu les recommandation
nutritionnelle donc ce travail est en
cours et devrait aboutir normalement
vers juin 2014 donc la question de de la
viande évidemment sera sera abordé alors
aujourd'hui dans dans l'actuel dans
l'actuel PNS
euh la viande est pas séparée elle est
elle est traitée avec le le poisson et
les œufs hein avec une recommandation
entretemps quand même il y a eu pas mal
d'évolution notamment des rapports sur
les nutrition et cancer que que l'un a
produit en reportant un peu les travaux
récents sur ces questions et qui poent
quand même notamment sur la viande rouge
des des risques d'association avec
notamment avec une probabilité qui
considéré convaincante par les les
organismes internationaux sur le cancer
colorectal euh et donc qui a qui ont
amené à à émettre des recommandations
supplémentaires de ne pas dépasser 500 g
de viande rouge par par semaine ce qui
est peu aujourd'hui on pense que la
consommation moyenne enfin la
consommation moyenne de viande rouge
elle est autour de de 320 g mais ça veut
dire que pour les percentiles élevés
donc les les forts consommateurs on peut
être largement au-dessus de de de ces
donc pour répondre très frontalement à
la question que vous nous avez posé qui
est de dire est-ce qu'il y a des
nutriments essentiels euh dans la viande
pas pas au sens pas vraiment en fait
c'est-àdire qu'il y a rien dans la
viande qu'on ne trouverait pas
spécifiquement dans les autres produits
animaux donc globalement pour pour je le
dis de manière tout à fait caricaturale
après il y a quand même un certain
nombre de débats par rapport notamment
la question du fer euh puisque le fer on
le trouve dans des produits végétaux
dans évidemment d'autres produits
animaux mais le la question du fer
éminique qui serait alors là il y a une
grosse controverse scientifique qu'on
est en train d'étudier sur est-ce que le
fer éminque est plus biodisponible et
donc serait mieux assimilable donc c'est
des des questions qui sont qui sont en
cours mais aujourd'hui globalement on
considère qu'il y a pas spécifiquement
par rapport aux autres produits animaux
une différence substantielle et des
nutriments de de particulièrement
d'intérêt qui ferait dire que une
sous-consommation de viande serait
problématique en revanche ce qu'on on
attire quand même souvent
l'attention dans le cadre des régimes
qui sont sans produits animaux du tout
bah que que ces personnes si elles n'ont
pas un historique
de familial ou culturel de de de
nutrition sans produits animaux soit
qu'ell se fasse accompagner quand elles
font ce ce choix-là et surtout qu'ell
fasse très attention à l'apport en
vitamine B12 notamment alors chez tous
les chez tous les végétaliens mais
essentiellement chez la femme enceinte
parce que la la carence en vitamine B12
chez des des femmes végétaliennes peut
avoir des conséquences très fortes pour
sur sur l'enfant et euh femme donc plus
de femmes que
d'homme oui non mais non mais euh vous
dites quand vous dites fr la B c'est
pour toute la population mais avec des
conséquences quand on est si on a un
homme végétalien il va peut-être manquer
aussi de B il va manquer de B1 et il
faut lui donner de la B1 en revanche si
si effectivement la transition a lieu
sur sur l'âge adulte on a on a moins
enfin les les les besoins on est moins
en phase de développement donc les
conséquences seront moins graves que sur
une femme enceinte avec un un enfant en
développement si en plus elle l'allite
derrière ce qui est souvent le cas des
femmes végétaliennes elle va
retransmettre il aura pas de B1 il y
aura des carences terribles et on peut
avoir des des des cas qui sont donc on a
on a fait récemment un communiqué de
presse à l'occasion d'un d'une sortie
sur les lait végétaux pour attirer
l'attention des notamment des des
futures mamans végétaliennes sur la
nécessité de de de complémenter leur
alimentation en vitamine B B 12 est-ce
qu'on est-ce qu'on peut simplement dire
que vous sous-entendez que la
consommation de viande n'est pas
mauvaise à la santé mais qu'il serait
judicieux d'en manger moins mais de
meilleure qualité alors sur la pour
l'instant je j'attends les révision de
des repairs du PN alors sur la qualité
vous posez une bonne question que
j'allais oublier que j'allais oublier et
j'attire votre attention sur un des des
un des travaux que qu'a fait qu'a fait
l'an sur l'impact de l'alimentation
animale cette fois-ci sur l'impact
nutritionnel sur la santé de l'homme de
l'alimentation animale notamment
qu'est-ce que quel pourrait être
l'impact de d'arrêter certaines graisses
saturées l'huile de palme l'uile de
copra dans l'alimentation animal sur
notamment la qualité des viandes du lait
et des autres produits animaux et donc
l'impact nutritionnel humain je pourrais
vous remettre ça on pourra vous
l'envoyer il fait un bilan un peu de de
de de de ces pointsl euh euh donc ça
c'est pour la partie je dirais un peu à
mon en fait sur cette question ensuite
sur la la question de la viande
effectivement nous sur la partie viande
rouge en tout cas il y a effectivement
des des éléments qui sont là très
objectifs dans la littérature sur
nutrition et
cancer sur le reste des viandes on est
en train de faire le le bilan de toute
la littérature sur l'apport protéique
hein de manière général sur le surpport
protéique et cetera donc il est trop tôt
pour vous dire ça sera dans les
recommandations du du du PNNS qui vont
venir en juin 2014 euh c'est des sujets
suffisamment compliqués parce que
beaucoup d'études épidémiux sont faites
par exemple aux États-Unis avec des
viandes qui ont pas du tout la même
qualité qu'en France donc ça demande
quand même beaucoup de peser les études
européennes vis-à-vis des études
américaines pas les mêmes consommations
bon après ça c'est il y a des des ratios
parce qu'il faut voir à partir de quand
le le le risque de cancer devient
augmenté ou le risque d'autres maladies
he notamment les maladies
cardio-ovasculaires donc tous ces
pointslà sont sont sont vus euh et après
il se trouve que c'est la qualité de la
viande n'est pas neutre non plus et
c'est pour ça que j'ai attiré votre
attention sur la nutrition des animaux
dont on voit que dans certaines espèces
en fonction de la quantité de fourrage
par rapport à la quantité de concentré
on agit sur les acides gras essentiels
qui sont dans la viande et on sait que
là pour le coup un certain nombre
d'acides gras essentiels ont des
répercussions santé qui sont importantes
voilà donc c'est difficile d'avoir une
réponse univoque sur la viande je pense
qu'il est intéressant de de dire
qu'effectivement la qualité de la viande
c'estàdire comment elle est produite va
peut avoir un impact un impact important
en terme nutritionnel on est bien dans
la qualité malgré tout oui voilà on est
bien dans la qualité malgré tout la
qualité de ce qu'on donne à manger aux
animaux que nous allons nous-mêmes
consommer euh par translation ça a quand
même une incidence ça une incidence
c'est ce que montre ce rapport pas dans
toutes les espèces parce que ça dépend
effectivement qu' si on est sur des des
monogastriques c'est pas tout à fait
pareil que sur des polygastriques ça ça
d'autres conséquences ça dépend des des
filières et donc il y a des des
scénarios qui sont faits alors qui
peuvent être quelquefis qui sont
réalistes quelque fois qui sont un peu
un peu utopistes avec des changements et
quel impact ça pourrait avoir certaines
fois ça n'en a pas certaines fois ça
aurait effectivement un impact en terme
de de qualité d'alimentation
humaine est-ce que vous avez prévu de
faire des études sur comment dire les
conséquences de l'alimentation animale
avec
OGM sur la qualité des viandes est-ce
que ça c'est dans vos plans ou est-ce
que c'est complètement
farfelu moi je peux je peux répondre un
petit peu mais ce qu'on a demandé c'est
quefin suite à suite aux articles de
notamment du professeur Seralini euh
c'est ce qui est on a demandé à ce qu'il
y a des études complémentaires de plus
long terme pour essayer de qualifier les
risques éventuel lié au aux OGM avec des
protocoles qui soient bien éprouvés
avant qu'on ne puisse pas critiquer
parce que il y a eu un certain nombre de
critiques qui ont été apporté à ces
études
euh par par différentes agences de
sécurité
sanitaire nous on a on a souhaité rendre
un avis enfin nos scientifiques ont
rendu un avis je dirais équilibré au
sens où certes il y avait quelques
quelques défauts méthodologiques dans
dans dans dans ce papier mais en même
temps il soulevait un certain nombre de
questions qui sont bah auxquelles il va
bien falloir répondre et et ce qu'on a
suggéré c'est qu' effectivement des
études mais qui soient financé par
l'État et ni par des associations ni par
des industriels euh ça coûte un petit
peu cher faut faut dire ce qui est mais
qui soit financé par l'État par des
labor dans des laboratoires indépendants
ça peut être alors l'an c'est pas
forcément armé en terme de de enfin nos
chercheurs sont pas forcément dans ces
domaines là enfin on travaille un petit
peu sur l'alimentation animale mais plus
sur les aspects relations avec la flore
intestinale par exemple ou des choses
comme ça euh on a des des enfin
notamment dans le laboratoire que je
dirige on a des installations pour pour
expérimenter un certain nombre de choses
mais je dirais qu'il y a des gens plus
compétents que nous pour ça alinra
notamment euh alincerme au CNRS si on
veut le faire sur des sur des souris et
il serait bien que on puisse trouver des
moyens de financer des études de long
terme euh bon après il y a énormément de
polémique effectivement il y a un
article qui est sorti euh avanttiier
dans un
journal sur sur un journal de
scientifique sur l'agriculture
biologique d'une équipe australienne et
néozélandaise qui montre que en
alimentant des porcs avec du du maïs et
du soja OGM on a une augmentation de de
la des inflammations gastriques et du
poids de l'utérus chez les truis euh
enfin chez les femelles là parce qu'on
c'est c'est pas encore des des truit
c'est juste avant la juste avant la
maturation sexuelle puisque c'est des
animaux euh en fait ils ont élevé des
animaux dans la sur la durée d'élevage
correspondant à à un animal qu'on va
consommer hein donc il y a effectivement
des répercussions possibles après j'ai
j'ai commencé à lire cette étude juste
en venant j'ai eu l'article ce matin
euh c'est il y a il y a tout un tas de
problèmes méthodologiques dans ces
études he il suffit que la granulométrie
de l'aliment soit pas tout à fait la
même chez le porc pour provoquer des
ulcères on peut simplement en changeant
de machine pour fabriquer les granulés
pour alimenter un porc on peut tuer un
porc avec un perforant donc c'est c'est
des animaux qui sont très sensibles aux
ulcères gastriques comme nous d'ailleurs
c'est un très bon modèle et donc il y a
il faut regarder s'il y a pas de
problème méthodologique certainement
reproduire mais en tout cas commence à
sortir un certain nombre d'études qui
pour le moins pose question et si ça
pose question bah il faut les confirmer
il faut lever les doutes s'il y a des
doutes à lever ou éventuellement ne pas
lever les doutes et dire il y a
effectivement un risque et je pense que
ça ça fait partie de nos de nos missions
euh tout au moins de promouvoir un
certain nombre de programmes de
recherche sur ce sur ce sujet là après
nous on travaille plus sur la détection
des OGM par des voies de PCR de de
biologie moléculaire dans les dans les
aliments on l'a fait mais mais on
travaille pas spécifiquement sur
l'alimentation on pourrait le faire sur
les volailles parce qu'on a des
installations qui qui s'y prêtent pour
le moment c'est pas trop le débat sur
les volailles parce que les durées de
vie sont très courtes alors que chez le
port c'est un peu un peu plus important
chez les beauovins encore plus
donc pour répondre précisément à votre
question c'est vrai qu'on a aujourd'hui
très peu de données sur on sait sur
souris effectivement que quelques études
montrent que l'alimentation avec des EGM
sur 2 ans peut avoir un impact sur la la
transcription donc des protéines au
niveau hépatique donc ça peut aussi du
coup avoir un certain nombre d'effets
sur le rapport des acides gras et cetera
donc sur la qual é effectivement des
viandes mais ça c'est suputatif parce
qu'on a on a très peu d'études donc on
les a appelé de nos vœux en terme de
suivi épidémiologique parce que c'est
vrai qu'on sait déjà pas vraiment quels
sont les animaux qui consomment et en
quelle quantité les OGM et d'où ils
viennent donc on a vraiment souhaiter
qu'il y ait des études de type
épidémiologique qui suivent à la fois la
santé des animaux et et c'est vrai la
qualité des produits qui en sont issus
parce que ils sont mangés par l'homme
derrière donc il y a un programme
aujourd'hui européen qui qui s'appelle
programme Marlon qui va qui va
s'intéresser à ces aspects
épidémiologiques chez chez l'animal
puisque c'est les plus difficile de les
documenter chez l'homme surtout en
Europe où il y a quand même de très
faibles consommations et que la
traçabilité est difficile à voir donc
c'est c'est des idées qui sont en cours
plus sur les aspects santé et moins
peut-être sur les conséquences en terme
de qualité des des produits mais c'est
des idées qui circulent et qui sont
intéressantes merci beaucoup merci c'est
très intéressant merci infiniment de
votre
collaboration tout à fait précise
fructueuse et qui va nous
aider c'est vraiment merci à vous
transmettre un certain nombre d'avis
qu'on a évoqué si ça vous
intéressesur sabour vous donne les
coordonnées
ma nous avons le plaisir de recevoir
Monsieur Daniel Peron conseiller du
ministre délégué chargé de
l'agroalimentaire monsieur Guillaume gar
accompagné de la l' tachée parlementaire
de monsieur Guillaume Garot mademoiselle
Vidal dont j'ai oublié le prénom Sarah
voilà
donc nous vous avons adressé un
questionnaire relatif à divers points de
l'action et de l'activité des activités
de Monsieur le Ministre de l'agriculture
dans le cadre de cette mission
d'information sur la filière viande qui
a été décidé par le Sénat à la demande
du groupe centr udi dont madame
gouachavan est membre et de ce fait elle
en est
rapporteur voilà donc cette mission
d'information porte sur les divers
diverses étapes on va dire de la filière
viande depuis les productions animales
en passant par l'abattage et les
industries de transformation qui sont au
cœur du ministre du ministère du moins
et je n'en doute pas au cœur du ministre
de l'agroal entaire ainsi que la
commercialisation alors la le
questionnaire qu'on vous a
adressé peut servir de trame à
notre conversation à notre à cette
audition peut-être que Madame Gavan a
quelques questions complémentaires à
poser même si neuf questions c'était
déjà conséquent elle va peut-être en
rajouter
une merci madame la Présidente je pense
qu'il y a des choses qui vont se
recouper mais
moi je voulais quand même revenir un peu
sur le sur sur le ce qui nous amène ici
finalement donc les révélations sur la
la présence de viande de cheval dans
nombreux produits préparés soi-disant au
bœuf hein ont mis en lumière des des
pratiques commerciales pour le moins
opaque et ont quand même sérieusement
émoussé l'image de la filière ou des
filières viandes les consommateurs ont
découvert l'existence du mineret euh ces
bas morceaux invendable autrement que
sous forme haché on en a vu d'ailleurs
lors de d'un d'un de nos de nos
déplacements euh ils sont souvent
d'ailleurs ces mineréss bouillis
plusieurs heures pour rentrer ensuite
dans la fabrication des saucisses et des
merguises enfin bon une fois mouliné
enfin euh c'est très surprenant haché
haché enfin on sait plus trop et on
découvre régulièrement malgré tout de
nouvelles fraudes alors afin de
restaurer la confiance des consommateurs
le ministre de l'Agriculture Stéphane
Lefol a énuméré deux objectifs fixés par
le gouvernement et les professionnels de
l'agroalimentaire alors progresser sur
l'étiquetage en indiquant l'origine des
viandes et rédiger une charte qui
renforce les contrôles afin d'éviter de
nouvelles fraude alors mais son d'après
son collègue donc le ministre délégué à
l'agroalimentaire donc monsieur garot la
France ne peut obliger les industriels à
retravailler leurs étiquettes car cela
est du ressort de l'Union européenne et
la démarche doit donc être volontaire
alors la première question c'est sur
quel pied
danse-ton dans d'autres circonstances la
France a su quand même imposer certaines
de
ces certains de ses souhaits et il
faudrait peut-être sur ce sujet-là sur
ce point-là qui est important pour les
filières viande peut-être un peu de
fermeté les industriels
d'agroalimentaire françaises comptent
plus de 13500 entreprises et plus de
400000 salariés l'agroalimentaire est le
premier secteur industriel national et
la France se situe au 4e rang mondial
quand même il faut le dire des pays
exportateurs de produits alimentaires
c'est donc un lobby extrêmement puissant
en France de nombreuses entreprises
agroalimentaires élaborent des produits
de très grande qualité mais aujourd'hui
elles sont mises en difficulté car faute
d'étiquetage adapté il est quasiment
impossible pour le consommateur de
différencier un produit de grande
qualité d'un produit médiocre
particulièrement dans ce contexte de
soupçon de de fraude généralisé même si
c'est pas le cas c'est c'est le soupçon
alors certains industriels semblent
quand même avoir un poids certain sur
les décisions des pouvoirs publics alors
quand sont pas des religions des
religieux sur l'abattage rituel ou les
viandes issues des filè à Lou cachè
alors moi je suis plutôt une libérale je
tiens à le dire mais il faut et je pense
qu'il ne faut pas tout réglementer tout
vouloir vouloir tout réglementer encore
moins tout interdire en revanche
pourquoi ne pas jouer la carte de la
transparence et dire enfin toute la
vérité au consommateur concernant les
produits qu'il achète euh pourquoi lui
cacher la vérité finalement plus que les
fraudes je trouve que c'est cette
opacité qui qui enfin cette opacité ne
contribue-t-elle pas encore à entretenir
un climat de défiance qui nuit gravement
à l'ensemble de nos filières viandes et
qui pourtant aujourd'hui font de la très
très grande qualité et qui pour autant
se retrouve en face de grandes grandes
difficultés voilà un peu plus qu'une
question madame la Présidente un peu mes
états d'âes mais je trouvais important
de profiter de votre visite pour vous en
faire part
voilà
alors la tâche est immense au-delà des
au-delà des neuf questions madame la
Présidente voyez mais il y en a qui se
recoup quandou des choses quioup C en me
répondant vous répondrez aux questions
et Visz verersa je
pense micro micro micro je vais d'abord
dresser un rapide panorama si vous me le
permettez de la filière telle que nous
nous la
voyons vousrz vous pourrez nous remettre
la feuille
écrite oui d'accord parce que
d'accordcord comme nous n'avons qu'une
heure et qu'elle est oui oui oui tout à
fait oui alors vraiment c'est vraiment
un très rapide panorama d'autant plus
que j'ai lu déjà les compte-rendus qui
sont sortis de votre de vos différentes
auditions et je pense que vous avez une
bonne connaissance désormais parfois
redondante d'ailleurs des choses donc
bon vous vous l'avez dit de toute
manière madame la
rapporteur c'est près de 500000 emplois
600000 si on rajoute les artisans
charcutiers et et boulangers c'est la
plus grosse industrie française ce qu'on
oublie souvent parce que c'est pas une
industrie de haute technologie en tout
cas pas perçue comme tel donc on oublie
son importance dans dans notre
poids c'est
euh donc une industrie vraiment
structurante pour pour les territoires
ruraux notamment en France et nous nous
le prenons en tout cas sous lesgit de
des ministres Stéphane Lefol et
Guillaume Garot comme agriculture
agroalimentaire comme quelque chose de
systémique d'une une économie systémique
structurante c'est vraiment ça qu'il
faut prendre en compte lorsque l'un
parle d'agriculture il a en point de
mire l'agroalimentaire lorsque l'autre
parle agroalimentaire il a en point de
mire évidemment l'agriculture donc ça
c'est quelque chose d'absolument
essentiel et la fragilisation ou la
fragilité d'un des deux maillons met la
fragilité du système
en rend le système fragile entièrement
donc ça c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
de notre point de vue complètement
prendre en compte c'est changer la
perspective finalement du système de
production de l'alimentation en France
c'est un système entier qui doit se se
penser encore une fois de point de vue
systémique alors une fois que j'ai dit
ça comment est-ce qu'on isole la viande
le secteur de la viande dans dans ce
alors pareil c'est tout à fait
systémique on devrait d'ailleurs
peut-être pas parler de filière viande
sans s il y a bien des filières et de
notre point de vue il y a des filières
c'est ou oui oui mais c'est vraiment
pour quelque chose d'absolument
essentiel lorsque l'on parle je sais que
vous avez auditionné le délégué
interministériel aux industries
agroalimentaires et à
l'agroindustrie lorsquon parle porort ou
lorsquon parle volaille même si nous
avons les mêmes objectifs qui sont la
qualité et l'emploi
euh la réalité c'est que les deux les
deux ne sont pas identiques les deux
sont pas confrontés pas forcément aux
même ch de même alors pour la viande
bovine c'est encore c'est encore bien à
part donc on a quelque chose alors au
sein des IA l'industrie des viandes
représentait en en 2010 hein selon les
les statistiques que l' en a 2462
entreprises donc Ctait en 2010 27 % des
salariés des
IA et seulement 20,8 % du chiffre
d'affaires
alors c'est vraiment un point important
pour nous et c'est sans doute l'un des
des nœud Gordiens de la réflexion qu'on
peut avoir sur la filière viande c'est
que son chiffre d'affairire est faible
par rapport à son poids relatif en
entreprise et en salarié ce qui tente à
prouver que on a un problème de valeur
des produits de valorisation des
produits et c'est autour de ça que
tourne tout le travail en réalité du
ministère depuis un an c'est vraiment
cette question là on exportait 11,1
% le taux d'exportation pardon é de 11,1
% et si on rajoute en revanche les
produits laitier on obtient là 41 % de
l'effectif salarié des
i donc si on parle hors produits
laitiers nous sommes à 27 % si on parle
avec les produits laitiers c'est 41 %
donc c'est un secteur avec effectivement
très très important et seulement 38 % du
chiffre d'affaires là encore on voit une
de valorisation sans doute du
produit globalement d'ailleurs je
voulais insister sur la question de la
valeur
ajouté depuis 2000 la valeur ajoutée
dans le secteur des
IA a stagné et a même légèrement
régressé puisquon était à 30,7 milliard
d'euros en 2000 et que nous sommes à
30,1 milliard d'euros en 2010 donc une
légère régression de la valeur
ajoutée et bien qu'étant la première
industrie elle elle contribue on peut
dire seulement pour 1,7 % de la valeur
ajoutée totale française en
2011 alors et si on regarde d'un point
de vue statistique régionale euh la
première région sans surprise c'est la
région Bretagne c'est 11 % de la valeur
ajoutée nationale et évidemment juste
derrière la Loire Atlantique sont les
deux bassins principaux euh de qui qui
ont qui sont aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
principalement les bassins fragilisés
pour certaines de leur
part autre point très important à notre
dans dans notre réflexion et dans dans
nos actions les entreprises de plus de
250 salariés en 2010 était seulement 2 %
représentait seulement 2 % de l'ensemble
des entreprises des
IA on avait 69 % de
TPE
et 29 % de
PME alors ça le chiffre brut peut
sembler peut sembler un
peu en faire beaucoup de place au TPE il
faut quand même le relativiser
puisque certes on a affire à des
entreprises de petite taille mais les
effectifs des entreprises de 20 salariés
et plus contrôlé par des groupes
dépassent 80 % dans 45 des régions
appartient à des groupes euh donc on est
bien dans une économie qui en fait fait
de la filialisation par PME on en
connaît un en ce moment on connait un
exemple malheureusement fameux en ce
moment c'est celui de spangero qui est
une entreprise qui appartenait à un
grand groupe et qui est qui app à une
Coopé voilà un grand groupe
coopératif groupe
et quand même un groupe industriel c'est
pas forcément une
coopérative oui il y a il y a il y a la
CCAB par ailleurs enfin l'ensemble des
des grands groupes si on regarde SODIAL
pour une autres
coopératives
donc alors les
coopératives les les
coopératives pardon ont un rôle ce que
vous venez de dire madame la Présidente
ont un rôle extrêmement important à
jouer ell représente 2266 entreprises en
2010 avec 50000 57000 956 c'est c'est la
la magie des statistiques
salariés donc on a vraiment une une
structuration assez équilibrée
finalement entre les secteur dit privé
et le secteur
coopératif le secteur coopératif étant
sans doute plus intégré dans certaines
filière type le lait apparemment ou il
est très
fort voilà pour le pour un peu le le
tableau
général je voulais revenir sur les
les la question du la question que que
vous posez sur la première question que
vous posiez sur le
panorama quels sont les secteurs les
plus en
difficulté je serais tenté de dire que
il n'y a pas systémiquement de secteur
plus en difficulté qu'un autre il y a
dans chacune
des dans chacun des secteurs on a des
diff difficulté dans certaines
entreprises alors le secteur si on veut
parler d'un secteur vraiment en
difficulté alors là on pourrait parler
de
de de la filière volail export qui est
effectivement très en difficulté c'est
lié problétique la problématique d' nous
avons deux opérateurs en France
principaux he c'est dou et tilisapco
effectivement c'est voilà on connaît les
difficultés
d'où essaie de se remettre de graves
difficultés depuis un
an manifestement on a de on a bonnes
raisons de penser qu'ils pourront s'en
sortir à C à cette date et à cette
heure les restitutions sont maintenues
mais vous savez madame la Présidente que
elle baisse donc l'objectif c'est de
pouvoir construire un système
qui puisse faire vivre ces entreprises
sans restitution on sait les ministres
sont l'ont dit très clairement les
restitutions ne sont pas éternelles on
ne sait pas elles ont été divisé par
deux en un début de cette
année il y a des clauses de revoyure
fréquemment tous les ans enfin plusieurs
fois par an donc ça on attend on sait
très bien que ça aboutira à un moment
les ministres se sont battus très
fermement et c'est Stéphane lefolle le
premier qui négocie à Bruxelles pour le
maintien euh de ces
restitutions nous verrons nous savons
aussi que malheureusement la France
n'est pas forcément majoritaire toujours
dans ces positions là vous le
savez donc la filière volaille Export
est effectivement en danger la filière
volaille d'ailleurs a une difficulté
c'est que nous importons aujourd'hui 30
% de la volaille que nous consommons
pour le poulet nous importons même 44 %
du poulaet consommer
euh c'est donc là un vrai problème de
structuration de ce que nous fabriquons
qu'il faut mettre en œuvre
c'est la question que nous devons poser
c'est que produisons-nous pour qui et
j'allais dire à quel
prix là nous avons une vraie difficulté
le principal de nos de nos concurrents
s'appelle l'Allemagne s'appelle les pays
du bénéuxe
c'est eux qui sont les principaux
concurrents sur le marché européen il
n'y a pas de raison a priori que nous ne
puissions pas rentrer dans la
concurrence avec ces
pays donc là il y a le un plan qui qui
doit être mise en uvre ce plan bien
évidemment fait
appel un certain nombre d'éléments que
le gouvernement peut appeler peut faire
lui-même comme la baisse du coût du
travail à travers le cice sur les
instruments de sur les instruments de
transform par exemple 4 % cette année 6
% l'année prochaine pour une entreprise
comme dou 2200 salariés 6% de baisse du
coût du travail on peut dire ce qu'on
veut mais j'ai pas entendu de critique
du point de vue des acteurs aujourd'hui
pour nous dire
que ça n'allait pas dans le bon sens
c'est vrai que c'est toujours mieux mais
mais reconnaissez quand même qu'en face
de la concurrence ENF du dumping social
de l'Allemagne c'est quand même
voilà qui pas forcment un bon modè
attention faut pas niveler par le bas
mais malgré tout est-ce qu'il faudrait
pas faire un peu pression malgré tout
sur l'Allemagne pour qu'elle Remon
qu'elle est enfin SP des niveaux de
couverture sociale quand même digne de
ce nom dans un pays européen la
directive détachement là-dessus est un
vrai problème nous l'avons dit le
président enfin le gouvernement le dit
le président de la République a lui-même
évoqué le sujet c'est un sujet qui doit
être négocié avec
l'Allemagne qui doit être négocié même
nous devons parvenir à un véritable
accord avec
l'Allemagne ce qu'il faut
dire favor elle est favorable
effectivement au SMIC puisquelle reprend
elle reprend
le voilà bon après on
verra nous savons aussi que nous n'avons
pas la même structuration sociale qu'en
Allemagne c'est-à-dire que ce sont les
secteurs qui font les salaires en
Allemagne donc on n pas on n pas une
comme chez nous
une
donc la question la question du salaire
minimum é é une vraie avancée nous
avançons bon c'est vrai que mais ce
n'est pas que ça si on regarde les
rapports il faut être aussi très
objectif si on regarde les rapports qui
ont été faits il y a deux ou trois ANSF
je travaillé à l'Assemblée nationale je
me rappelle d'un rapport Reyes sur le
sujet ou plus
récentemétion voilà ça varie
àassemblé depuis depuis que nous
travaillons sur ce sujet le cgaer a
travaillé sur ces sujet la question du
coût du travail est réelle mais ce n'est
pas ce n'est pas la seule c'est aussi la
question des outils de l'investissement
dans les outils de transformation
pendant 10 ans certains n'ont pas
investi dans leurs outils de
transformation alors que nos concurrents
ont des usines neuves ont des
poulaillers neuf alors vous allez me
dire c'est plus facile de construire un
système que de le changer nous nous
sommes confrontés à un système qui
aujourd'hui fonctionne depuis j'allais
dire le début des années 60 tel qu'il
est avec des poulaillers qui sont
relativement anciens avec des usines
anciennes c'est vrai que nos concurrents
notamment allemands ont des poulaillers
beaucoup plus récents ont des usines
beaucoup plus
récentes des abatotoir extrmement
Robotis des abatoirs robotisés et cetera
cet effort qui demandera d'ailleurs
aussi à la France un gros effort de
formation des salariés quelque chose
qu'on oublie toujours on parle toujours
des IA on parle souvent des agriculteurs
derrière on parle très rarement en tout
cas beaucoup trop apparment des salariés
des IA qui sont trop peu
formés dans un certain nombre de
secteurs et qui mérite une attention
toute particulière quand on sait ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui d'un point de vue
social euh les lieu où ça peut craquer
c'est autour de ces salariés qu'il faut
faire l'effort et ça la transformation
de l'outil de travail de l'outil de
transformation d'abattage puis de 2e ou
3e transformation ensite nécessite
vraiment de notre part pouvoir public et
acteur économique un effort considérable
en France il faut sans doute mettre en
place des formations parce
qu'aujourd'hui on nous dit qu'on trouve
plus de boucher et il faut mettre en
place des formations à la fois à
l'abattage à la boucherie pour valoriser
ses métiers et leur
permettre de de d'avoir un salaire digne
de ce nom parce que c'est quand même un
peu aussi ça le problème alors ça je je
je partage complètement c'est d'ailleurs
l'un des l'un des objectifs du contrat
de filière qui a été signé la semaine
dernière il y a tout tout un volet
emploi dans le contrat de filière et
notamment emploi et
formation alors il faut être aussi très
objectif il y a une volonté tout
simplement aussi à la base d'avoir des
formations de premier niveau apprendre à
lire et écrire on s'est rendu compte
lorsque le groupe dou a eu ses
difficultés qu'au moment des plans
sociaux un certain nombre de salariés
étai tout simplement incapable de
remplir les fiches qu'on leur donnait à
remplir par sil Savit pas lire c'est sûr
ou plus lire plus écrire
alors en outre dans un certain nombre de
secteurs il y a des des personnels
d'origine étrangère non francophone à
qui on noffre pas beaucoup de ces
formations et il est très clair les
salariés les les IRP demande des
formations de base savoir lire et écrire
c'est la première chose pour pouvoir
ensuite retrouver un travail la grosse
difficulté qu'on a c'est d'avoir des des
personnels qui puissent faire autre
chose et puissent même penser qu'il
puisse faire autre chose ça c'est l'un
des c'est l'un des des points majeurs
sur lequel travaille Guillaume Garo
aujourd'hui c'est s'occuper de ces
personnels alors il y a dans le contrat
de filière quelque chose qui est qui est
de ce point de vue très intéressant
c'est c'est les
CCP avec la volonté de faire des ccup
transvau qui permettrait de
passer d'un secteur à l'autre dans
l'agroalimentaire ça c'est un travail de
vraiment de de structuration de
politique de filière générale
agroalimentaire qu'il faut mettre en
œuvre ça se fait avec les évidemment
avec les partenaires sociaux c'est une
demande et on a vraiment de de bonnes
raisons de penser que là aujourd'hui
tout le monde est bien conscient de ses
responsabilité aussi bien point de vue
gouvernemental mais
ça pas besoin de ajouter à cette idée
que le l'emploi est vraiment la priorité
des priorités mais du point de vue
patronal puisque ils se rendent compte
aussi que dans l'attractivité des
métiers vous parliez tout à l'heure de
de l'attractivité des métiers madame la
la
rapporteur ça compte beaucoup vous savez
très bien
que on nous l'a encore des acteurs nous
l'ont encore dit
récemment dans certains secteurs on dit
si vous ne travaillez pas bien à l'école
vous irez à
l'usine d'abattage
c'est pas une bonne image que l'on donne
du
secteur voilà oui mais après il faut pas
non plus
euh les agroalimentaires sont très
différents travailler dans une usine de
lait où tout est automatisé où les gens
sont des opérateurs derrière ordinateur
et travailler sur une chaîne d'abattage
ou travailler sur une chaîne de
charcuterie à la main ça n'a rien à voir
c'est des salariés très différents vous
passez du BTS à la personne qui a
strictement pas de diplôme comme je vous
disais tout à l'heure il sait pas
lire donc là il y a une vraie difficulté
à prendre en compte et pour nous c'est
c'est l'un des enjeux majeurs en tout
cas 4re points si vous me permettez sur
le contrat de filière quatre points ont
ét mis en avant de ce point de vue c'est
consolider et créer des emplois
notamment chez les jeunes ça veut dire
les attirer les
jeunes les jeunes quoi les jeunes
éleveurs les
jeunes dansindustrie je parle moi que de
l'industrie pas
compét qualité pour parler de l'élevage
avant du secteur
préalable donc c'est consolider et créer
les emplois c'est très important
sécuriser les parcours professionnels
c'est ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure avec les CP si plus on a de la
formation plus on peut on peut
sécuriser donc améliorer
activité du secteur et des métiers de
l'alimentaire en règle générale et
effectivement renforcer le dialogue
social dans les
territoires dans les branches et dans
les entreprises c'est une demande très
forte des
salariés et de fait la la filière s'est
engagée à former et recruter 150000
jeunes sur la période 2014-
2017 ça veut dire 10000 jeunes de plus
en réalité que le flux
habituel vous allez créer des formations
ils vont être formé ENF il y aura de la
formation en alternance il y aura des
contrats de professionnalisation il y
aura des contrats
d'apprentissage il y a évidemment aussi
la la mise en œuvre al d'ici fin juillet
en réalité sera négocié et signé un
accord interbranche là sur les contrats
de génération donc c'est essayer
vraiment de de réinscrire les i Dans un
futur quelque chose que j'ai pas dit
dans dans le propos liminaire et qui est
absolument
essentiel l'agroalimentaire en France a
un futur et nous pensons même qu'il a un
futur
florissant je rappelle juste une chose
le défi alimentaire mondial du 21e
siècle fait que la France a toute sa
place dans la production de
l'alimentation mondiale elle a toute sa
place et ces industries agroalimentaires
ont toutes leur place pour deux raisons
le
savoir-faire qui nous est globalement
envié dans le monde entier et la qualité
de ces produit et de notre point de vue
en tout cas il est fort dommageable que
ça soit de la France que vienne le
dénigrement permanent de nos productions
et de la et de la qualité de nos
produits il y a des raisons à ça vous
parliez tout à l'heure de la fraude a
des raisons
mais je ser tenté de dire un fraudeur ne
doit pas caché la forêt des gens
vertueux oui mais si vous permettez
parce que je dois vraiment partir mais
quand même quand dernier facicule que
vient de publier le ministère de
l'agriculture avec gros titre produire
autrement agriculture produire autrement
si vous voulez l'agriculture c'est
maisagriculture produire autrement moi
j'ai réagi à ce fasicule quand même hein
c'est sateur
agroalimenta sateur la même chose he on
a dit tout à l'heure que c'était la même
chose c'est justement on a dit que
c'estit la même choseant vous venez de
dire F des nigr mais c'est le ministre
lui-même qui dénigre monsieur monsieur
monsieur le sénateur je pense
que non non mais monsieur le sénateur je
vais je je vais vous répondre très
simplement c'est pas parce qu'on produit
avec moins de pesticides et qu'on suit
ce qui a été fait dans le Grenel de
l'environnement et qui a été voté par
les deux Chambres de façon très large à
une époque que je rappellerai pas c'est
pas parce qu'on suit cette ce ce
mouvement- là qu'on veut qu'on change
euh enfin je veux dire qu'on ne change
pas le reste de de l'agroalimentaire
c'est il y a la production l'impact sur
l'environnement et d'ailleurs produire
autrement ça permettra aux éleveurs si
je puis me permettre de rattraper une
partie du défaut de compétitivité à
l'égard de nos amis allemands puisque à
travers notamment le plan EMA le plan
méthanisation ou autres nous avons là de
la ressource supplémentaire pourquoi
est-ce que les Allemands sont si
compétitif c'est parce qu'ils sont allés
je vais employer un terme vulgaire ils
sont allés à fond dans ce système là
peut-être pour certains trop loin mais
c'est ça le prod ça représente ça ou ça
si vous voulez dans la production mais
il y a tellement d'autres chose dans la
production euh ne serait-ce que le
travail des éleveurs de montagne et
cetera les pesticides ils connaissent
pas ce que c'est moi c'est dommage que
uniquement pour les pesticides on dit
agriculture produisant autrement si vous
m'excusez uniquement parce qu'on va
parler des pesticides qui vont
représenter que Monsieur B ils seront
ver par définition je ne pas pas
le verdissement par définition
voilz à bientôt excuseo de rien
monsieur donc alors je reviens sur donc
les contrats de
génération il y a aussi donc ce que je
vous disais tout à l'heure les
formations sur les savoirs fondamentaux
avec 5000 salariés supplémentaires qui
auront accès à des à des formations sur
les savoirs fondamentaux alors 5000
salariés ça peut paraître
faible
bien sauf que c'est déjà 10 fois plus
que ce qui a été fait l'année précédente
donc en 2012 donc lorsqu'on demande 5000
sur les 3 ans qui viennent c'est juste
10 fois plus que ce qui a été fait
l'année dernière donc ça il faut prendre
en compte cette demande des salariés qui
est dire sur le terrain ça va se passer
comment dans une entreprise un salarié
va dire j'ai envie de faire une
formation pour apprendre à lire et à
écrire vous pensez que ça va êtrecile
oui c'est oui c'est une vraie demande he
oui oui c'est une vraie demande c'est
aussi une demande alors je serais tenté
de dire c'est c'est c'est malheureux
mais c'est une demande qui a été faite
au moment de d'un certain nombre de PSE
de de de sauvegarde pour l'emploi
simplement apprendre à sair lire écrire
quoi on a on a des on a à faire à
des un personnel
euh pour un certain nombre encore une
fois he c'est pas tout hein c'est je
faut pas euh mais pour un certain nombre
d'usines d'entreprises de
secteur on a à faire à des personnels
qui sont sur du travail plus subi c'est
le rapport rouau he qui expliquait bien
ça il y a eu un rapport du du
cgaer en 2010 sur le sujet du travail
aussi qui expliquait bien qu'il
s'agissait plus de travail subi que de
travail choisi pour un certain nombre de
ses salariés
euh tout l'objectif des deux ministre
c'est de donner de redonner de la
noblesse àes à ses métiers
euh personne ne mangera de la viande
s'il y a pas quelqu'un pour la battre il
a traité et la et d'abord la et d'abord
la produire oui mais moi excusez-moi je
suis voilà alors effectivement
l'objectif tout est lié peut pas trop
saissonner si vous Perm monsieur
bretenou monsieur bretenou reviendra euh
oui oui oui on lui en parlera reviendra
sur le sujet l'objectif effectivement
vous parliez des secteurs en difficulté
port aussi volaille donc on en a parlé
le port aussi nous sommes confrontés à
une baisse de la production et c'est là
où effectivement nous
travaillons totalement en lien
effectivement avec avec avec le ministre
de l'ro de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire de la forêt c'est que
il faut maintenir un seuil de port à 25
millions hein de tête n nous avons
baissé de 2 millions il faut maintenir
ça pour maintenir des outils moins nous
aurons de production moins nous d'outil
par définition la restructuration
puisque c'est l'une des questions que
vous posez sur la fin moins jet de
production plus la restructuration se
fera
sauvagement par
définition voulez poser une question sur
la production de porc il y a quelque
chose qu'il faut commencer par le début
autoriser la construction de
pocherie je vis un département qui est
le 6e
département de France en
superficie
sonoir qui est le premier département de
France en surface agricole utile il y
est interdit dessus d'y construire une
porcherie interdit parce faut commencer
interdit parce que parce qu'il y a des
écolos de partout ceuse-moi oui il est
pas légalement interdit oui mais ça même
le résultat même le problème alors
là-dessus là-dessus non mais non mais
attention si le la production de por
baisse ça ne tient qu'à ça parce qu'il y
a un tas de gens qui ont envie
et c'est rentable de faire du por nous
en sommes à ce point conscient que oui
mais quelque chose pour pour bouger la
VI le ministre a déclaré que les
procédures ICPE allaient être àoup voilà
c'est j'allis av nous allons nous allons
trouver le faut trouver la solution vite
hein parce que ça va vite actuellement
la solution sera discutée ou en fait la
solution sera discuté en juilletin pas
depuis
10 Ah oui il y a 10 ans que demand
fallait le faire je suis moi nous nous
sommes là depuis un an donc nous faisons
la non mais voilà moi je suis je je je
veux pas me moi la question pour moi
n'est pas de savoir ce qui a été fait ce
qui n'a pas été
fait pas jamais par contre il faut il
faut une décision sérieuse sur làdessus
çare facile monsieur le sénateur nous
avançons vraiment il y a une volonté
politique je crois qu'elle n'a jamais
été aussi forte d'avancer sur la
question des ICPE il y a une prise de
conscience peut-être nait-elle pas été
de part je n'incrimine personne de part
et d'autre pas réel à une époque il est
vrai que nous souffrons aussi d'une
image de la production du port liée à
l'hyperconcentration bretonne faut le
dire et que les gens ont peur parce
qu'ils ne connaissent pas il est plus
facile il est plus facile d'implanter un
poulailler malgré tout c'est ce qu'on
nous dit hein c'est voilà mais en tout
cas sociétalement il est plus facile
d'implanter un poulailler que
d'implanter un élevage de porc et on le
voit même dans des secteurs euh bon il
s'avère que nous connaissons un peu la
Mayenne pour des raisons que et lors
effectivement en Mayenne il y a pas de
problème d'algue verte par exemple
puisque tout le monde est focalisé sur
ce problème là
et l'image de l'éleveur de porc est
celui du pollueur ce n'est plus vrai ce
qu'il faut prendre ce n'est plus vrai et
je vais je vais même vous dire non
seulement nous nous allons changer les
ICPE mais nous allons permettre
l'augmentation de la taille des élevages
et nous allons montrer ça c'est
effectivement un travail de persuasion
que nous devons faire et que nous
faisons nous allons démontrer qu'une
grosse exploitation qu'un gros élevage
n'est pas forcément plus polluant qu'un
petit élevage c'est très clair et c'est
à partir de ça cette reconquête de la
production que nous pourrons conquérir
de nouveau la transformation et la
question qui nous au ministère délégué à
l'agroalimentaire nous interroge le plus
c'est bien l'évolution de ces outils de
transformation oui ça c'est absolument
essentiel et c'est là-dessus que nous
travaillons c'est là-dessus que nous
allons le secteur du port est plus
compliqué que les autres faut être très
objectif le secteur du porp est plus
compliqué il y a une plus
grosse concurrence entre les
acteurs nous avons des acteurs qui sont
globalement plus petits que la moyenne
européenne par ailleurs donc il y a sans
doute une restructuration du secteur à
faire mais cette restructuration ne doit
jamais se faire sur le dos des salariés
si je pe me permettre ni des éleveurs le
moi je voudrais parce que le temps passe
très très vite et il y a une part
importante de notre travail qui concerne
l'étiquetage la transparence euh voilà
j'aimerais savoir ce que vous proposez
pour restaurer la confiance du
consommateur en matière d'information
sur les
produits brut et surtout
transformé alors alors vous n'évacuez
pas pour autant le le contrat de filière
vous nous communiquerez les éléments
figura dans le rapport bien sûr je me
suis permis tu l'as mené tu l'as sorti
contrat contrat de filière de vous en
amener la l'entièreté
alors sur sur la traçabilité c'est un
sujet qui
est pvons pas c'est un sujet qui est un
sujet de droit
européen c'est un sujet qui nécessite
donc
l'accord l'accord européen pour la pour
l'étiquetage obligatoire ceci
dit au niveau national il est possible
que les acteurs sur
la foi du volontariat s'empare du sujet
et
étiquette il n interdit à aucun acteur
par exemple d'étiqueter OGM ou
sansogm aucun il n'est interdit à aucun
acteur de dire viande française ou pas
viande française d'ailleurs sur le VPF
ça marche très bien sur le
port ça marche bien ça marche bien sur
leort le volontariat est suffisantc uits
transform sur les produit transformés
non très clairement alors le 21 mai
dernier il y a une réunion donc à la
suite de l'affaire que
connaissez qui s'agissait d'améliorer
les contrôle de la qualité la
traçabilité et l'étiquetage des origines
des plats cuisinés à base de
viande et donc nous avons le
gouvernement a relevé différentes
orientations qui sont d'abord des
orientations nationales puis des
orientations
européennes d'abord au niveau national
c'est la mise en place d'une charte
antifraude des contrôles renforcés entre
fournisseurs et acheteurs de viande pour
la
transformation les entreprises les
entreprises donc doivent rendre publ
leur engagement dans cette
démarche il s'agira ensuite de définir
des standards professionnels
à travers un code des usages qui est
relatif à la qualité pour la viande
utilisée dans les plats préparés et
effectuer les contrôles physiques et
analytique
nécessairire ce code des usages sera
applicable dès l'automne
2013 nous devrons
aussi anticiper le renforcement de la
réglementation
communautaire et mettre en œuvre donc le
plus rapidement possible les démarches
volontaires d'étiquetage de l'origine et
le renforce des contrôles de la qualité
des viandes donc on n demand on
demandera pas l'étiquetage on nimposera
pas l'étiquetage sur les produits
transformés nous ne pouvons aujourd'hui
légalement pas
l'imposer le droit ne nous permet pas
cela vous auriez la volonté de le faire
si nous avons la volonté de le faire
alors au niveau national je finis juste
le 4è point qui est promouvoir la
démarche de type VBF ou VPF alors aussi
sur d'autres filières comme les l'ovin
ou la ou la volaille donc là il y a il y
a toute
une cette démarche d'ailleurs va avec
l'idée de valeur ajoutée c'est nous nous
considérons que produire français c'est
mieux
produire donc nous considérons que les
acteurs ont tout intérêt à dire qu'il
produisent
français et donc sur des au niveau oui
pardon sur des produits de
transformation un
industriel du pâté il peut mettre il
peut il a il a le droit transformé
il la base volontaire je n'ai pas le
droit en tant qu'État de le lui imposer
aujourd'hui il a le droit en tant
qu'acteur économique de le
faire au niveau européen le gouvernement
s'est engagé à promouvoir l'utilisation
des codes et usages qui sont relatifs à
les codes des usages pardon sont
relatifs à la qualité dans les
différents domaines de production à base
de
viande
nous avons aussi poursuivi le diog
dialogue pardon avec les autorités
européennes pour obtenir un étiquetage
de l'origine des viandes jusqu'au stade
des plats transformés c'est une demande
des trois ministres le fol garot amont
au niveau européen nous le demandons et
nous persistons à le
demander et nous espérons bien y
parvenir en tout
cas nous allons demander enfin nous
avons renouvelé la demande de création
d'un réseau antifraude
alimentaire je je vous donnerai le le
document nous allons aussi veiller à ce
que au niveau européen à ce que les les
obligations en matière d'enregistrement
préalable de traçabilité et d'accès aux
informations pour les autorités de
contrôle soit étendu aux sociétés de
trading de viande quelque chose que le
grand public a
découvert effectivement une min les
trader le minerel les traders il il est
effectivement alors très clairement le
minerai c'est
euh quelque part ça démontre ce qui est
devenu euh j'allais dire l'objet animal
une fois
mort voilà pour l'industriel on en a vu
à terminer et euh demain oui et on en
verra demain et j'avoue que j'imaginais
pire je sais pas euh oui non non mais
bon donc vous savez dans l'histoire dans
l'histoire de minerais madame on en a vu
qui font bouillir plusieurs heur et il y
a celui qu'on aurait mis dans un plat de
côte en gros pour simplifier plusieurs
sortes quand même c'est que le minerai
correspond à l'idée de pousser au
maximum la rentabilité des des outils
industriels et des animaux que l'on AAS
faut être très clair êre objectif et ça
c'est la pression économique qui amène à
ça c'est une de vos questions et et je
je me permettrai d'y répondre vous vous
dites est-ce que les fraudes
alimentaires sont le résultat de la
pression sur les des prix bas
euh sans doute en partie sans doute un
certain nombre d'acteurs économiques qui
ne peuvent plus résister sont amenés à
employer des pratiques qu'il
réprouverait par ailleurs sans doute
c'est un facteur sans doute maintenant
des fraudeurs il y en aura tout toujours
même dans un système florissant et
économique il y aura toujours des gens
pour trouver qu'ils ne font pas assez de
bénéfice mais effectivement aujourd'hui
on est dans un système où qui tirant
vers le bas en permanence les
prix ne peut qu'attaquer la qualité au
bout d'un moment c'est
clair et c'est autour de ça et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça notamment que nous
avons travaillé et que nous proposons
une réforme de la loi de modernisation
de l'économie qui permet
de de répercuter en tout cas de
renégocier les prix à travers l'article
62 de la du projet de loi euh relatif à
la consommation qui permet d'avoir une
clause de renégociation des prix en cas
de volatilité des des matières premières
sachant que il est essentiel pour le
gouvernement que cette renégociation se
fasse à la hausse comme à la
baisse mais euh ça c'était un point un
point clair c'est ça doit être à la
hausse comme à la baisse pour les
acteurs ça remet aussi à la hausse aussi
pour les producteurs oui oui parce que
bon voilà souvent il faut reconnaître
que l'agriculteur l'éleveur c'est la
variable d'ajustement mais mais que du
coup on voit beaucoup d'éleveur mettre
la clé sous le paillasson on voit RAR
rarement la grande distribution en
grande grande difficulté donc je pense
que le ministère a sans doute quelque
chose à faire aussi dans cette direction
là j'en dirais pas plus je vous laisse
réfléchir là-dessus non non mais très
clairement sur sur la la grande
distribution elle a le rôle qu'elle a
qu'on a bien voulu aussi lui donneré
politiquement la LME a un objectif très
clair à la base moi je me souviens j'ai
travaillé sur ce texte l'objectif
c'était de faire baisser les prix on
peut pas un jour dire je veux faire
baisser les prix et le lendemain se
plaindre que les entreprises ne vivent
plus des prix qui sont pratiqués c'estd
baisser les prix oui mais pour le
consommateur pas baisser les prix à
l'achat ENF entre les deux il y a tout
le monde n pas a des g plus malheureux
que d'autres dans il y a des gens
beaucoup plus malhe des maillons plus
plus malheureux que d'autres sur la ch
nous nous pensons c'est que chacun des
acteurs tout au long de sa filière et là
je parle du producteur et même celui
avant producteur d'aliments qui donne au
producteur du producteur jusqu'à
distributeur doit pouvoir faire une
marge qui lui permet de vivre et lui
permettre de vivre c'est pas survivre ça
lui permet de faire de former son
personnel ça lui permet d'innover
d'investir pourquoi est-ce que les IA
aujourd'hui sont en grande fragilité
pour une grande part pour une part
parfois importante d'entre elles sur
certains secteurs c'est tout simplement
parce que depuis quelques années elles
n'ont plus les moyens d'investir
d'innover et de rester j'allais dire
dans la course à la compétitivité avec
leurs concurrents et ça c'est absolument
essentiel quand on fait moins de 1 % de
marge ou quand on fait des marges
négatives plusieurs années d'aff est il
est impossible à une entreprise de
survivre et il y a un choix systémique à
faire et le très clairement il a été
fait c'est de retrouver de l'équilibre
dans les relations commerciales pour
permettre à chacun de vivre c'est
essentiel et ça ça a été c'est un choix
qui est complètement assumé qui est
volontaire et sur lequel nous tiendrons
bon jusqu'au
bout par
ailleurs une chose est absolument
essentielle les acteurs économiques ont
leur rôle à jouer là-dedans les
négociation commerciales en
France sont décrites notamment par le
président de l'Observatoire des prix et
des marges comme quelque chose
d'absolument
ubuesque par rapport à ce qui se
pratique à
l'étranger c'est un monde effectivement
très dur les relations commerciale il y
a un moment où chacun doit rend se
rendre à la
raison clair et et le gouvernement
là-dessus ne peut pas négocier à la
place descteurs les
prix mais il a en revanche le devoir de
permettre une négociation équilibrée ce
qu'il a fait en revoyant la LME à
travers l'article 62 la médiation aussi
tu peux
dire oui de même effectivement nous
avons mis en œuvre et ça à l'égard des
des éleveurs notamment la médiation sur
le prix du lait la mé son sur le prix du
porc
euh c'est des choses qui aujourd'hui
apportent quelque chose de tangible pour
pour les
éleveurs nous devons absolument encore
une fois c'est systémique si l'industrie
agroalimentaire ne vit pas si je n'ai
pas de transformateur si je n'ai pas
d'abatteur en Bretagne je n'aurai plus
d'éleveur de porc en
Bretagne si je n'ai pas de
transformateur de lait en Auvergne je
n'aurais plus d'éleveur laitier voilà
oui mais bon il faut quand même
valoriser le produit français ça Fran
parce que j'ai l'impression de de
marteler une évidence mais les produits
français les productions de viande
française sont de grande qualité et on
ne les valorise pas au travers du non
étiquetage finalement et ça c'est c'est
très dommageable pour pour l'industrie
agroalimentaire les acteurs économiques
les acteurs économiques doivent le
valoriser et encore une fois sur
l'étiquetage l'état puisque nous sommes
dans un système EUR
euréen l'État ne peut pas imposer un
étiquetage qui est interdit au niveau
européen en revanche les acteurs
économiques peuvent le faire et c'est à
eux de le faire c'est à eux de valoriser
le VPF c'est à eux de valoriser le VBF
aujourd'hui l'État peut peut-être donner
un petit coup de pouce dans ce sensl oui
il donne c'est ce qu'il fait il donne il
il incite il c'est toute la valeur
ajoutée je parlais tout à l'heure d'une
difficulté de valeur ajoutée notamment
dans le secteur de la viande c'est ça
toute la valeur ajoutée est là c'est
aussi une bataille de
Laé de la qualité de
l'image oui effectivement
ou fait bien de me le
dire nous allons
construire un logo général qui est
labelle viande de
France qui permettra un petit peu de
regrouper l'ensemble des secteurs qui
permettra notamment d'avoir des
conditions sociales le
label
donc donc c'est avec une charte sociale
et cetera donc on est là sur un sur un
élément absolument important du travail
je crois que au
bout au bout d'un an de travail avec les
IA dans toutes les régions de France
avec le contrat de filière tel qu'il
sort nous parvenons à à
créer sans doute un élan qui n'avait pas
été donné depuis très très longtemps aux
I qui qui se sentaiit sans doute enfin
c'est ce qui nous a été dit
régulièrement oublier du secteur c'est
un secteur qui a très peu
été finalement dont on s'est très peu
occupé oui alors justement vous avez dit
à juste titre que il y avait pas eu les
investissements nécessaires et on nous
l'a dit en
Bretagne très clairement aussi le plan
d'investissement d'avenir vous pouvez
nous en dire quelques
mots je peux vous en dire quelqu ou nous
donner une fiche je vous donnerai
ensuite inv alors voilà je vous donnerai
par ailleurs les les fiches
nécessaire il y a un plan donc de ce
qu'on appelle le pacte pour
l'investissement
productif qui est un plan de financement
du secteur
agroalimentaire monsieur le ministre
Stéphane Lefol a expliqué qu'il fallait
créer une dynamique d'investissement
territorial soutenu évidemment par les
pouvoirs publics
qui se mobilise là pour le coup à tous
les niveaux c'est on est bien état
collectivité dans un objectif vraiment
offensif pour ce secteur c'est il n'y
aura pas de redressement productif sans
redressement de
l'agroalimentaire ça c'estil faut en
être tous parfaitement conscient il y a
trois dispositifs principaux de soutien
impliqu l'État et les régions qui ont
pour pour soutenir le financement des
investissements productifs alors au
niveau euréen nous avons le fader
oui alors il est doté globalement de de
près de 10 milliards d'euros sur
2014-2020 et le deuxème pilier de la PAC
prévoit parmi C ces nombreux dispositifs
la la possibilité de soutenir la mise au
point de de nouveaux
produits des procédés et techniques dans
le secteur de l'agroalimentaire donc il
faut utiliser cela quand c'est
nécessaire on a les aides apportées au
projets de recherche d'innovation etvel
des industries agroalimentaires
aussi et on a l'instrument
BPI qui est doté lui globalement de de 2
milliards de 42 milliards d'euros en sa
totalité et sur lequel on aura une
ventilation dans les semaines qui
viennent faut savoir qu' en 2000
201 les industries agroalimentaires av
avaient investi plus de 5 milliards
d'euros don don 3 milliards d'euros pour
pour les les
PME nous
avons pour justement alimenter ces
projets d'investissement nous avons fait
remonter
donc par les par les services de l'État
et les conseills généraux 750 projets
donc nous avons identifié 750 projets
d'investissement pour un de plus de 2
milliards enfin de 2,7 milliards d'euros
aujourd'hui alors ça c'est que les
projets dans les pouvoirs publics ont
connaissance c'est évidemment un certain
nombre d'entreprises ont des
connaissance vous envisagez de valoriser
les productions de proximité
ou alors vous voulez vraiment partir que
sur la la la grosse industrie les gros
abattoires ou est-ce queon va continuer
à à promouvoir quand même un peu pe la
proximité surtout en zone de montagne
par exemple avec des des chaînes
d'abattage voilà de proximité nous avons
coutume de dire que l'agroalimentaire
doit marcher sur ces deux jambes il y a
les productions de
masse très clairement qui répondent à
une demande qui est celle aussi du
pouvoir d'achat il faut être très clair
donc nous ne reviendrons pas sur ce
modèle c'est ainsi mais nous avons à
côté des circuits alors moi je préfère
appeler circuit de proximité plutôt que
circuit court parce un circuit court ça
peut être un intermédiaire entre la
Roumanie et et
nous par exemple
donc le circuit de proximité oui ça fait
partie des des jeux c'est il y a deux
jambes le secteur agroalimentaire la
production alimentaire à deux jambes
d'un côté ce que je serais tenté
d'appeler la la relocalisation des
productions avec encore une fois des
modèles de production
alimentaire territorialisé je cherchis
le mot excusez-moi territorialisé l'un
des exemples c'est la promotion des
labels nous continuons de promouvoir les
labels nous continuons de penser que les
labels ou autre sont une source de
richesse considérable pour notre
agroalimentaire et je pourrais dire que
l'extraordinaire réussite du secteur
viticole français àex montre que le
système des AOC est aussi compatible
avec une exportation de nos produits
donc de ce point de vue
l'agroalimentaire est tout à fait il n'y
a pas pour nous
euh de mauvais projets il n'y a que des
projets qui permettent de faire vivre
les territoires et les salariés sur les
territoires donc petit ou grand pour
nous ça n'a pas euh c'est ou
oui vous avez parlé de dou et vous avez
dit que bon la restructuration était
nécessaire et qu'elle était possible
envisageable en tous les cas et euh on
vous avait interrogé sur gade là où par
contre il n'y a pas de repreneur annoncé
à moins que je n'ai raté un épisode ce
qui peut
arriver surgade nous n'avons pas
d'information
euh ça
va vendredi prochain
euh ce vendredi
ce vendredi il y
auracis une présentation par
l'entreprise pour l'instant nous nous ne
sommes pas
informés de ces questions qui plus comme
vous le savez dans ce type de
procédure les salariés doivent avoir la
primeure de ce qui va se faire donc en
plus
gons pas d'information précise sur le
sujet nous ne sommes pas plus informés
que la presse en tout cas à mon niveau
moi conseiller je ne suis pas plus
informé que la
presse avez-vous d'autres questions bon
on va passer maintenant au conseiller du
ministre de
l'agriculture en vous remerciant de
votre et puis informations que vous
pouvez nous laisser soit sous forme
écrite soit sous forme m on va
vousenvoyer
par c'est plus
facile V les
conseillers du ministre de l'Agriculture
de l'alimentaire et de l'alimentation
devraisje dirais de la
forêt en la
personne les personnes de Monsieur
jean-uillaume
bretenou de Monsieur Bruno Ferrera qui
est conseiller pour le ministre
au sécurité
sanitaire et madame Claire
bretenau brenetau les bretenou breneto
et et sachez que j'ai passé de jours à
Strasbourg au Conseil de l'Europe où
j'ai essayé de de faire des choses et je
suis rentrée un peu fatiguée ce matin
donc vous voudrez bien nous excuser
enfin m'excuser de mélanger un petit peu
les noms bien
alors vous savez ig de cette mission
d'information sur la filière viande
causée par le scandale du
cheval qui donc remplacer le bœuf dans
certaines production de produits
transformés cette mission d'information
a été demandé par le groupe centriste
udi au Sénat et Madame gouachavan qui
est
rapporteur fait partie de ce
groupe qui a demandé qui a sollicité
donc cette mission
d'information cette mission se décompose
en trois grandes parties les productions
animale d'une
part le secteur de l'abattage et des
industries de transformation dont votre
collègue Daniel Peron vient de nous
parler plus çaallit dire plus
précisément et puis le commerce nous
avons fait un certain nombre d'auditions
je crois que nous en serons autour de 65
ou 70
c'est-à-dire que nous avons et vous
elles sont disponibles sur le site
d'ailleurs de la
mission presque toutes me dit Cédric qui
n'a pas eu le temps de d'écrire les
dernières ou de mettre en ligne les
dernières nous avons fait un déplacement
à
Bruxelles où nous avons rencontré la DG
SANCO et la DG Agri pour ce qui
concernait les productions animales nous
sommes allés jusqu'à l'AE rencontrer la
ministre de l'Agriculture ainsi que ses
services et un certain nombre de de
d'acteurs économiques dont un trader qui
a volontiers reçu notre petite
délégation c'est vrai que nous n'étions
pas très nombreux mais on a bien profité
puis un expéditeur enfin transformateur
de viande qui exporte beaucoup de viande
notamment de bœuf vers la France et vers
la restauration hors
domicile nous sommes allés en Bretagne
nous avons examiné successivement la
filière porsine et la filière volaille
et demain nous serons à l'invitation de
Monsieur Beaumont en sonn etloire puis
dans l'in à l'invitation de Madame la
rapporteur donc vous voyez que nous
avons fait un travail sérieux fouillé
euh il nous manquait une pièce maîtresse
malgré tout dans notre dispositif
c'était l'audition des représentants du
ministre à défaut d'avoir le ministre
qui négocie par ailleurs la politique
Agri agricole commune et qui doit être
fort occupé donc nous sommes heureux de
vous rencontrer nous vous avons adressé
un questionnaire qui va servir de base
si vous en êtes bien d'accord à cette
audition et Madame gouachavan a
peut-être une question supplémentaire à
vous poser chaque fois peut-être
d'illeur redondante avec les questions
que nous avons déjà envoyé mais je lui
donne la parole merci madame la
Présidente c'est faaire bien huilée hein
c'est la dernière audition ah ou et donc
voilà ça ça fonctionne bien merci
beaucoup madamees messieurs d' d'être
avec nous aujourd'hui alors je vous je
vais vous expliquer quelque chose puis
vous allez voir où je veux en venir le
31 mai dernier lors de l'assemblée
générale du syndicat national de
l'industrie de la nutrition animale vous
avez évoqué au nom du ministre de
l'agriculture les difficultés et
l'avenir de
l'élevage à cette occasion chacun a bien
pu mesurer combien la vision de
l'élevage des représentants de l'agro
l'agroalimentaire contrastait avec la
position du gouvernement un intervenant
a notamment déclaré je cite alors la
tendance vers une intensification de la
production animale continuera dans les
décennies à venir elle est non seulement
inéluctable mais également souhaitable
je cite hein bien sûr elle est en fait
la condition cinequanon pour concilier
la performance économique et les
exigences de durabilité que nous impose
la société civile c'est en tout cas la
conclusion très claire à laquelle est
arrivée la fameuse commission vanourm au
Pays-Bas fin de citation alors rappelons
que cette commission composée de
représentants de toute les la filière
agroalimentaire qu'elle s'est donné pour
mission de définir un projet pour en
particulier donc la province du
nord-braban mais je vais vous dire
pourquoi je je parle de cette province
c'est la province néerlandaise avec la
densité de population en port et en
volaille la plus importante d'Europe
Europe donc sacrément concurrentiel pour
la France dans ses conclusions donc
cette commission estime que la taille
optimale d'un élevage pour une
exploitation économiquement viable et
durable est celle qui permet d'employer
quatre équivalent temps plein cette
taille d'après eux permet en effet de
procéder au aux investissements
nécessaires pour le bien-être et la
santé de l'animal le respect de
l'environnement et cetera et cetera
alors bien sûr le nombre correspondant
euh n'est pas du tout le même qu'en
France sans aucune commune mesure le
nombre d'animaux dans l'entreprise dans
l'exploitation ça n'a rien à voir avec
la
France pour Monsieur Christian Rena qui
est expert associé au bureau d'étude and
international l'intensification de
l'élevage en France est une
nécessité les opérateurs je cite
dominant imposeront leurs normes pour
tout le monde et il dit encore
l'avantage prix d'un filet de poulet de
Hollande est de 10 % ce qui est énorme
avec de plus grand de plus gros volumes
des l'eau plus homogène et dit-il un
parage mieux fait alors dans ces
conditions moi j'ai envie de vous poser
une question le modèle français avec de
petites entreprises est-il toujours
viable est-il amené à disparaître plus
ou moins long terme peut-il y encore
avoir plusieurs modèles d'exploitation
en France des petites ou des grandes et
et pour illustrer mes propos avant de
vous laisser la parole et sans doute de
rebondir on fera é change euh il existe
pourtant sur notre territoire des
modèles d'exploitation bien différents
et aussi des modèles innovants avec des
des initiatives très intéressantes alors
j'ai rencontré vous aussi parce qu'il me
l'a dit donc par exemple monsieur Kurt
déboucherie André à Lyon qui nous
propose un modèle un nouveau modèle
d'organisation et j'imagine qu'il y a
d'autres types d'organisation innovante
comme celle-ci mais c'est c'est celle-ci
que je que j'ai c'est ce monsieur que
j'ai rencontré un nouveau modèle
d'organisation donc très innovant
maîtrisant toute la chaîne du prê à
l'assiette en veillant entre autres à la
qualité de la production de
l'alimentation donc voyez ça ça démarre
très très tôt dans la fabrication de
l'animal j'ai envie de dire et bien sûr
en veillant au bien-être animal pour
produire une viande d'excellence alors
que beaucoup prôent le modèle un modèle
plus industriel plus intensif
qu'avez-vous prévu au gouvernement pour
soutenir ce type de modèle innovant et
j'ai envie de dire moderne finalement
dans cette société où on nous parle
presque d'usine comme on nous l'a dit en
Bretagne d'usine par exemple de bless
sur pte en nous parlant des
poulets tout d'abord bonjour Merci pour
votre pour votre question al il y a
beaucoup de de questions et de sous
question je pourrais commencer en disant
qu'on ne croit pas quand je dis on va
dire le ministre Stéphan fol pour être
plus plus précis ne crois pas au fait
qu'il y ait un seul modèle qui soit
valable pour pour l'ensemble de de
l'élevage que d'ailleurs pour toutes les
pour toute l'agriculture et qui a qu'un
seul type d'agriculture valable quel que
soit quel que soi les les productions
euh il est évident qu'il y a une forte
tendance une forte pression enfin il y a
une vision de l'agriculture qui est
celle que seule la taille peut permettre
d'être toujours plus compétitif à la
fois en Europe mais aussi probablement
sur les marchés internationaux par
rapport à des des concurrents
internationaux certains considèrent
qu'il y a que en étant toujours plus
intensif qu'on peut éventuellement
compenser les différences d'autres
différences euh en terme de coûp de la
main d'œuvre ou de normes
environnemental qu'on peut avoir avec
des pays tiers par exemple
euh c'est c'est vraiment pas ce
qu'onorte et d'ailleurs vous avez
vous-même donné une partie de la réponse
à la fin de votre question en disant
voilà la conception que le ministre a de
l'agriculture ou en tout cas de
l'élevage c'est pas d'être complètement
déconnecté du territoire des cult et
c'est pas d'être une activité de
transformation comme finalement on
classe l'élevage dans une activité de
production et pas dans une activité de
transformation si on peut dire comme
l'abattage ou je sais pas ou la ou le la
transformation de de blé en farine et
cetera donc on est vraiment nous on
considère le ministre considère que on
est vraiment au niveau de la production
qu'il faut qu'il y ait un lien au
territoire donc c'est vrai qu'il y a
au-delà de l'approche strictement
économique et de
compétitivité qui d'ailleurs serait
probablement discutable c'estàd est-ce
qu'on est certain que on est plus
compétitif avec une avec une très grosse
exploitation qu'avec une exploitation on
va dire de taille familiale sachant que
c'est pas enfin ça peut être il y a
plusieurs exceptions derrière c'est déjà
pas complètement évident qu'il a aussi
des problèmes notamment dans l'élevage
de maladie ça Bruno pourrait probement
complétter mais la le fait qu'on a des
des élevages très regroupés dès qu'on a
un problème une maladie ça a des
conséquences immédiate très importante
sur la production et sur la le risque
disons sanitaire est encore plus
important disons et les conséquences
économiques mais au-delà même de ces
questions de compétitivité la vision la
vision du gouvernement je pense de de de
l'élevage c'est aussi aussi une activité
qui a un enjeu territorial et
socio-économique de localisation de la
production sur tout le territoire de la
production et de la transformation en
conséquence et donc concentrer la
production dans quelques exploitations
qui seraient probablement toutes à peu
près au même endroit parce que si on dit
ça on dit rapidement qu'en gros on
spécialise les régions les régions qui
qui qui des régions qui font plus que
grandes cultur des régions qui font plus
que de l'élevage de façon très
concentrée et à ce moment-là on a aussi
un problème d'aménagement du territoire
derrière d'occupation de l'espace et
c'est absolument pas la
vision politique qu'on peut avoir de de
de l'agriculture et en particulier de
l'élevage donc d'ailleurs si on défend
aujourd'hui l'élevage enfin des si
l'élevage est une des priorités du
gouvernement et du ministre de
l'Agriculture que ce soit dans les
négociations de la PAC ou sur tout un
tas d'autres d'autres questions c'est
aussi parce que on considère que
l'élevage
y compris VI a la transformation est un
facteur de de de croissance de
développement économique et d'occupation
du territoire sur tout le territoire
français donc c'est vraiment ça ça la
vision qu'on peut avoir donc donc
derrière évidemment découle l'idée
immédiate qu'il y a pas de modèle unique
et qu'on ne privilégie absolument pas un
modèle les modèles des modèles très
intensifs ou avec des exploitations de
très grande taille dans le même temps
pour peut-être anticiper une sousqu il y
a aussi des projets en France d'élevage
de grande taille qui se développe donc
il y a la fameuse ferme des mille vaches
il y en a d'autres à d'autres endroits
mais c'est vrai c'est plutôt la ferme
des mil vaches qui est la plus
emblématique la f voilà après c'est une
exploitation c'est un projet qui a été
étudié très attentivement qui rentre
dans les dans les conditions
réglementaires qui sont posées
oui c'est dans le c'est en enin
maintenant c'est d'ailleurs plus que 500
enfin c'est la ferme de 1 vaches
commence
avec plateau de000 vach quand même chez
moi donc alors rebaisser le nombre de
vaches ça évitera les confusions
géographiques d'accord en bon maintenant
c'est une fer 500 vaches mais bon le
projet était de 1000 vaches au départ
non mais disons que il y a un
encadrement réglementaire donc il y a
pas non plus d'interd enfin il faut être
clair il y a pas non plus d'interdiction
en France à des projets de ce type là à
condition qui respectent tout toutes les
normes réglementaires ce qui fait
qu'effectivement le projet a été très
encadré et avec des conditions très
strictes et une surveillance qui sera
très stricte mais le projet a été
effectivement autorisé comme projets de
grande taille ailleurs peuvent être
autorisés parce que il y a pas non plus
de de de raison de de pas de de
d'interdire en tout cas
réglementairement on ne peut pas
interdire un tel projet et ensuite un
tel projet ça peut aussi porter des des
des pistes
d'amélioration technique de la gestion
environnementale de l'impact
environnemental d'une exploitation de
grande taille et cetera donc on ferme
pas non plus voilà c'est pas c'est
clairement pas le le type de modèle de
production d'élevage que qu'on promeut
et que qu'on veut appuyer après c'est un
c'est un projet qui respecte les règles
et qu'on peut pas peut pas écarter alors
je je peux aussi alors le dernier aspect
de votre question après on peut rentrer
plus dans les détails c'est comment
est-ce qu'on soutient plutôt le maintien
comment est-ce qu'on accompagne le fait
de pas de de d'une part de freiner mais
aussi de donner la possibilité à des
exploitations de plus petite taille
d'être encore viaable et d'exister sur
le sur le
territoire il y a deux volets à ça je
pense que une des premières réponses
c'est quand même la le projet de
surdotation des 50 premiers hectares
pour les aides de la de la politique
agricole commune donc qui a été dans
dans les discussions qui se sont
conclues aujourd'hui à Bruxelles donc il
y a quand même l'idée de de mieux doter
les 50 premiers hectares parce que ça
correspond plutôt à derrière ça c'est
quand même des élevage de taille euh
c'est plutôt en faveur des élevages à
taille familiale on va dire enfin disons
avec
euh euh un chef d'exploitation ou deux
chefs d'exploitation et cetera donc ça
ça correspond plutôt à à à ce modèle- là
ça c'est la première piste la deuxième
piste c'est aussi l'idée du produisant
autrement c'est-à-dire et de
l'agroécologie c'est-à-dire comment
est-ce qu'on peut développer sur des sur
des modèles qui correspondent au projet
à ce projet politique de taille
d'occupation du territoire comment
est-ce qu'on peut améliorer la
performance économique et
environnementale de ces exploitations
pour pour leur permettre d'être plus
viable donc c'est vraiment ça aussi
aussi le sujet c'est c'est de dire voilà
les exploitations aujourd'hui elles sont
peut-être pas aussi compétitive encore
que c'est ce qu'on disait au début ça se
discute qu'une très grosse exploitation
mais peut-être qu'elles peuvent l'être
si elles améliorent leur performance
économique environnementale une
meilleure gestion de de leur une
meilleure gestion de de leur de à la
fois leur pratique égronomique de leur
conduite d'exploitation une meilleure
vision une meilleure sécurisation de
leur revenus sur la durée et pas et pas
à court terme tout tout ce genre de chos
qui est porté par le ministre dans le
dans le cadre du projet
agroécologique je m'en tiens là bon
monsieur fer oui bonjour également je
voudrais juste compléter et donc
rebondir sur un élément que vous avez
cité madame la sénatrice c'est la
destination également de la production
animal qui est celle d'être un aliment
et que à travers justement des modèles
également de d'exploitation de plus
petite taille on a également toute la
dynamique qui est très très porteuse en
France notamment des signes de qualité
sur les productions animales notamment
je pense aux productions de volail mais
pas uniquement et on a également des des
des signes de qualité je sais que dans
dans votre département c'est un
important mais on a également ces signes
de qualité qui se développent sur
d'autres productions on a des signes de
qualité sur le port sur les veau sur les
sur sur les bovins de façon général sur
les in donc toutes les les démarches qui
visent à une segmentation du marché
permettent également une valorisation
plus importante des productions et
permettre une agriculture de proximité
qui se basant sur des des exploitations
de plus petite taille permett de dégager
également des des facteurs de
compétitivité importants pour maintenir
un autre type d'agriculture qu'une
agriculture uniquement tournée vers l'
sensivité alors je vais rebondir sur
Bruno excusez-moi pour dire que
effectivement vous avez un moment dans
dans votre dans votre question dans
votre question vous avez aussi évoqué le
fait moment qui qui est obligé de partir
sans doute souiterit poser une question
alors j'avais juste un mot à vous dire
c'est pas même pas une question je
participe tout à fait à cet aspect de
l'agriculture tel que vous l'avez décrit
tel que le décrit d'ailleurs Stéphane
lefold régulièrement de ce côté-là on
est tout à fait d'accord il y a pas de
souci sauf que sauf que quand même pour
certain secteurs et je pense à en
particulier parce que je ce que je
connais le mieux je suis vétérinaire
j'étais vétérinaire rural donc en bres
donc j'é j'étais laitier si vous voulez
bien la production laitière production
laitière aujourd'hui et c'est là que le
gouvernement do s do s'en inquiéter vous
avez parlé des 500 vaches mais les 500
vaches c'est vraiment l'avenir parce que
actuellement on est en train de fermer
les productions les tiers se
disparaissent de partout y compris dans
mon secteurù son remplacé par des vaches
charolaises c'est un gros avantage la
vache charolaise ça se traite pas alors
que la la
vache les tiersr ça se traite deux fois
par jour tous les jours j tous les jours
tous les jours de l'année samedi
dimanche Noël et tout ce que vous voulez
compris et ça c'est un repoussoir
aujourd'hui pour les jeunes alors vous
avez les situations et moi j'en ai j'en
ai déjà quatre dans mon départ dans la
Bresse de de ferme de 150 hectares de
150 vaches avec des robots
mais il faut 150 vaches pour amortir
pour amortir le robot correctement
pouvoir le payer et vaches à vach à et
là il y a plus de traite c'est
merveilleux la vache va se traire toute
seule ça produit plus de lait d'ailleurs
au passage pu que quand la vache vient
de V en particulier elle se laisse trire
trois fois volontiers par jour donc elle
produit plus le le client est gagnant en
quantité il est assez gagnant en qualité
parce que bon l'animal est identifié il
a sa dose de farine tout tout est
automatisé il suffit de d'y passer quand
même mais d'y passer d'y jeter un œil ça
peut être le voisin ça peut être
n'importe qui qui jette un œil et voir
si tout marche tout marche bien mais en
principe ça marche très très bien et
c'est vraiment exceptionnel il faut voir
ça et ça ça va révolutionner les
production laitière mais ça va ça ça
suppose des aides importantes au départ
parce que c'est un coup hein ça n'est
pas hors sujet puisque les lai tières
fournissent une bonne partie de la
viande bah oui c'est elle qui en
fournissent le plus hein voilà donc qui
en fournissait le plus ça va pu être
vrai voilà je voulais vous dire ça parce
que c'est un point sur le plan je pense
que sur le domaine laitier ça ça a
vraiment un impact très fort alors que
chez moi je voyais fermer les les fermes
de enfin transformer les fermes
en en fermes de de production de viande
et en on commence à manquer on commence
à manquer de lait en France hein on
importe du lait en France déjà vous êtes
mieux passé que moi pour le savoir que
excusez-moi je peux pas PIR discuter
avec vous plus longtemps j'aurais bien
aimé j'ai un train il faut que je parte
à 7h10 merci beaucoup à demain 10h30
chez Bigard chez
Bigard je
continue des éleveurs de proximité mais
c'est vrai que la question de la
pénibilité du travail et du évidemment
et des contraintes évidemment et voilà
et la productivité du travail pour un
éleveur est bien moindre que pour un que
pour un cérali ce qui évidemment pose
question alors mais dans le produisant
autrement il y a un peu aussi dans le
modèle c'est comment est-ce qu'on peut
s'organiser pour justement aussi pouvoir
avoir avoir les contraintes et
s'organiser ça peut passer par du
collectif ça peut passer effectivement
par des robots avoir un robot c'est pas
forcément non plus avoir 500 vaches je
pense que c'est plutôt un robot par par
tranche de mais pour moi j'avais plutôt
en tête qu'un robot c'était par tranche
de 50 vaches mais mais mais bon enfin
c'est donc c'est pas voilà entre 150 et
500 il y a aussi une petite différence
potentiellement et ce que je voulais
dire par rapport à Bruno c'est aussi le
le point que vous avez évoqué et qui
renvoie aussi un peu à cette image un
peu fantasmatique autour de la ferme de
1000 vaches ou de 500 vaches c'est
effectivement il y a une demande aussi
en France de la société par rapport au
mode de production qui est peut-être pas
la même en Hollande ou dans d'autres
pays du norde spécificité culturell
voilà donc ça renvoie ce que à ce que
disait Bruno sur les signes de qualité à
un moment donné aussi il y a une forte
demande par rapport à ça c'est une
caractéristique quand même française
donc ça il faut en tenir compte
euh donc le on peut pas non plus être
que dans dans une idée que toute la
production doit passer en production
standard parce que c'est le plus
efficace économiquement en terme de
compétitivité ça veut pas dire non plus
qu'il y a pas de la place pour la
production standard en France donc il
faut effectivement avoir un marché bien
segmenté et ne pas gâcher cette
segmentation en essayant d'être tous que
tout le monde soit sur le même segment
donc il y a de la place aussi pour des
gens qui seraient qui produiraient un
coout compétitif pour être en balance
avec des productions on va parler si on
parle de volail hollandaise belge ou
allemande mais voilà il y a aussi cette
segmentation qui existe pas forcément
dans d'autres dans d'autres pays alors
alors toute l'équilibre à trouver c'est
c'est à la fois garder garder notre
segmentation et en même temps sur les
les produits plus standard éviter aussi
d'être dans
la dans la la démultiplication d'avoir
chaque enseigne qui demande qu' a des
prescriptions différentes je suppose que
vous avez eu lors de vos auditions des
question sur ce point-là c'est quelque
chose sur lequel on travaille et ça
c'est pas lié enfin le fait qu'une
enseigne que chaque enseigne demande une
taille de barquette ou une couleur
différente et cetera ce qui ce qui qui
coûte beaucoup plus cher au niveau de
l'abatotoire ça ça n'a aucun lien avec
la taille de l'exploitation au départ ni
ni ni même voilà une exploitation de
petite taille peut aussi faire une
production très calibrée et très
standardisée enfin on le voit dans
d'autres c'est il y a eu beaucoup de
progrès aussi et le produ autrement ça
peut être ça aussi d'être capable de
mieux calibrer de mieux conformer à sa
production c'est moins pour les volail
c'est plus facile pour d'autres
productions de type bvin auovin c'est
quelque chose sur lequel les les les
producteurs ont beaucoup travaillé ils
se sont aussi beaucoup améliorés dans le
domaine pour répondre plus
spécifiquement à la demande et ça c'est
aussi une voie qui dépend pas forcément
de la taille de la taille de
l'exploitation moi je voudrais juste
rebondir sur ce qui a été dit tout à
l'heure parce que à ce stade de la
conversation on ne peut pas ne pas
l'évoquer je crois que les les
agriculteurs les éleveurs
aiment fondamentalement leur métier le
problème c'est que c'est pas tant la
pénibilité c'est pas le temps de devoir
traire des vages tous les jours c'est le
problème de se dire pour des
investissements énormes je vais gagner à
peine le SMIC si tout va bien je crois
que il faut remettre les choses dans
leur contexte nos agriculteurs nos
éleveurs euh ne gagnent pas suffisamment
par rapport à leur investissement
personnel et aux investissements
financiers qu'ils font je crois que
c'est ça qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que est-ce qu'on accepterait de
faire autant d'HE que pour gagner aussi
peu c'est ça aussi alors un jeune quand
on va lui dire bah tu sais tu vas
travailler je ne sais combien d'heures
par semaine tu vas devoir investir
tantter plus ta ferme et ton tracteur
vont appartenir au créricole pendant des
années et si tu gagnes le SMIC sois
content on a rencontré un jeune qui a
repris une exploitation famille familial
en volaille et qui nous annonçait tout
content que je suis content je gagne le
SMIC enfin vous voilà je crois qu'il
faut il faudrait revaloriser la
production agricole et revaloriser le
statut de l'agriculteur et le les
revenus de l'agriculteur je crois que
c'est souvent malhe on le redit on l'a
dit plein de fois hein c'est la variable
d'ajustement du systèmeoute et j'ajoute
que chez les céréaliers tout va très
bien
donc qu'on peut prendre aux uns pour
donner aux autres tu me donneras un coup
de main quand on parlera de mais
volontiers madame la Présidente d'avenir
de l'agriculture je compte sur toi pour
me pour me le redire non mais je pense
que voilà je crois que c'est pas tant la
pénibilité ils aiment leur travail que
ce soit en port en volaille en beauin il
y a pas de souci on a des jeunes qui ont
envie de de de reprendre les boîtes
familiales alors on parlera tout à
l'heure des normes hein parce que quand
on voit un jeune qui nous dit moi il me
faut entre euh j'ai mis 5 10 ans avoir
une réponse pour l'installation de de de
mon entreprise pour avoir une fin de N
recevoir et ça coûte 50000 € enfin c'est
pas concevable il faut que on et je sais
que vous avez dans les tuyaux des des
des idées donc vous allez nous en parler
c'est pour ça que je vous mets sur ce
sujet il faut qu'aujourd'hui les
dossiers d'installation et
d'agrandissement d'exploitation soi
traités dans un temps limite 6 mois
comme comme dans chez nos voisins et
puis que les demandes de pièces
complémentaires se fassent dans un temps
limite aussi genre 15 jours on peut pas
balader des agriculteurs leur demander
des des tas de d'études pour construire
un poulailler une stabulation truc ENF
voilà je je c'est un peu le le cri du
cœur parce que ça m'a tellement été dit
qu'il faut vraiment qu'aujourd'hui je
vous le dise et que vous nous fassiez
des proposition pour les aider dans ce
sens on est d'accord qu'il y a un effet
double ou triple peine pour les éleveurs
entre la pénibilité du travail le revenu
bien moindre que les céréaliers qui qui
qui ont beaucoup moins de contraintte de
travail plus effectivement des
contraines réglementaires qui qui qui
sont qui sont probablement plus pesantes
pour les telleles qu'ell sont
aujourd'hui pour un éleveur que pour un
que pour un producteur de grande culture
donc c'est vrai qu'il y a y a tout tout
ça fait effectivement qu'il y a cette
tendance à se dire pourquoi je
deviendrais pas producteur de grande
culture pour les gens qui le peuvent
parce qu'il y a aussi la problématique
de ceux qui n'ont pas vraiment le choix
enin c'est-à-dire qu'il sont quand on
est agriculteur dans une zone
intermédiaire probablement là ce que
disait monsieur bon c'est euh évidemment
on peut avoir le choix on peut se dire
bon ben je vais changer de production
puisque je peux faire un peu de tout si
je suis dans une zone de polilyculture
élevage je peux devenir 100 % euh grande
culture quand on est dans des zones plus
plus difficiles où on peut pas basculer
en grande culture ben on est éleveur où
on n'est pas où on n rien et donc c'est
là aussi qu'il faut c'est ça aussi qu'il
faut consolider alors sur sur la la
partie procédure et simplification
administrative c'est vrai qu'on a tout à
fait conscience de la des difficultés la
la problématique en fait on la pose un
peu sous sous de la façon suivante quand
la procédure devient dissuasive même
pour quelqu'un qui rentre complètement
dans les règles c'est qu'il y a un
problème quand les gens ne ne font pas
de projet d'agrandiss ou d'installation
d'un bâtiment ou de modernisation de
leur bâtiment parce que la procédure est
trop pénible alors que ils respectent
ils ont tous les tous les arguments pour
respectecter les contraintes ou les
exigences on va dire plutôt les
exigences environnementales qui sont
posées sur
l'agrandissement l'installation d'un
nouveau bâtiment c'est là où c'est là où
il y a vraiment un problème donc c'est
pour ça que qu'effectivement pour
l'élevage porin qui est le plus
contraint aujourd'hui et sur lequel il y
a effectivement le plus de différence
entre ce qu'on pratique au niveau
français et ce qui se pratique ailleurs
en Europe on a la
la le souhait ou la vol exprimé par le
ministre et validé par le par le Premier
ministre de créer un régime
d'enregistrement qui devrait faire
passer le délai de 12 mois au minimum
pour un agrandiss pour une création de
bâtiment dans la dans la de taille qui
qui de taille couverte par ce nouveau
régime alors on dit 12 mo minimum mais
en pratique c'est plutôt 18 mois ou 24
mois à 5 ou 6 mois dans le meilleur des
cas ce qui ce qui commence à devenir un
délai raisonnable pour avoir un projet
et avoir des perspective et commencer à
se lancer dans un projet donc ça c'est
le passage d'un régime de d'autorisation
qui suppose une enquête publique une
étude d'impact un régime
d'enregistrement où effectivement
quelqu'un qui arrive directement avec un
dossier bien ficelé pour avoir une peut
peut faire l'objet d'une décision
préfectorale beaucoup plus rapide avec
sans sans remise en cause des exigences
environnementales les exigences
environnementales sont les mêmes si
jamais il y a effectivement un
questionnement sur l'impact un
questionnement sur l'impact et cetera
dans des cas précis qu'il faudra
encadrer et définir précisément on peut
rebasculer sur un régime d'autorisation
quand on est dans des dans des dans des
situations particulières qui nécessitent
d'aller plus loin et de de mieux
explorer ça mais pour les gens qui sont
dans des dans des dans des choses bien
cadrées et qui peuvent rouler
normalement ça ça permettra d'aller
d'aller beaucoup plus vite sans remise
en cause des exigences environnementales
parce que le sujet derrière quand même
et ça je pense vous en êtes bien
conscient vous l'avez pratiqué c'est que
on a derrière aussi une demande forte de
la société d'avoir des des un
encadrement très strict de ces de de ces
de ces production des installations et
en particulier des des installations de
production de de grande taille et donc
on est obligé aussi de de de répondre à
ça et et d' d'en tenir compte alors
peut-être que dans d'autres pays il y a
aussi moins cette cette cette cette
cette cette sensibilité de la société
sur le sujet mais en France on est
clairement obligé d'en tenir compte et
c'est c'est quelque chose qui qui est
une borne assez de laquelle on enfin à
laquelle on peut pas échapper qu'il faut
prendre comme un comme un paramètre
difficile à difficile à modifier dans
l'état actuel de de la perception de la
de de la société sur ces sujetslà il y a
des histoires de seuil d'installation
classéqu qui sont pas les mêmes selon
les pays donc il faut peut-être faire
quelque chose aussi justement on a un
seuil beaucoup plus bas et l'idée c'est
justement entre notre seuil plus bas et
le seuil européen de créer ce nouveau
régime d'enregistrement qui accélère la
procédure sans remettre en cause les
exigences environnementales mais qui
permet d'avoir quand même à monter un
dossier avec prouvant qu'on respecte le
le les décision avec décision du préfet
qui est donc un régime très encadré mais
qui va aller beaucoup plus vite que que
le le régime d'autorisation qu'on
pratique en France sur des exploitations
de plus petite taille et alors que c'est
pas le cas au niveau européen je peux
vous donner les seuils si vous voulez
enfin je sais pas si je suis clair je
suis clair c'est pour les animaux pour
les Pors c'est entre 450 et 2000 Pors
aujourd'hui on a un régime
d'autorisation alors qu' en Europe on a
un régime de déclaration qui est un
régime très alléger donc on passera un
régime intermédiaire d'enregistrement
comme on a dans l'élevage létier ou dans
d'autres élevages qui permet d'aller
beaucoup plus vite mais avec un
encadrement strict parce que on voit
bien que le le remonter les seuils c'est
quelque chose qui est pas qu'on peut pas
porter et qui qui qui avait été porté
par le gouvernement précédent et qui
n'avait pas réussi à aller au bout donc
c'est pas une question de c'est pas une
question de gouvernement ou voilà LE FUR
c'est l'amendement le fameux amendement
Le Fur qui avait été rejeté sous le
gouvernement précédent donc c'est pas
une question de de de je pense de de de
majorité et cetera c'est une question
d'attente et d'attente de de la société
sur le sujet faut peut-être le
représenter différemment les choses
murissent non mais juste les producteurs
en sont conscients et aujourd'hui la
création d'un régime d'enregistrement
c'est qui qui qui se
fera est déjà quelque chose qui est vécu
comme un très bon signal comme une
volonté dire on est prêt à ce que vous
puissiez moderniser vos exploitations à
produire et ça c'est un signal
aussi ça va donner quelque chose de
concret administratif aussi c'est aussi
un signal psychologique très fort d'une
volonté de de de pas brider non plus les
les projets qui parilleurs sont innovant
et moderniser son exploitation c'est pas
seul c'est aussi ça peut être aussi
limiter son impact environnemental c'est
ça quand même qui a derrière bien sûr
c'est paradoxal on va l'empêcher de se
moderniser et donc il polluera plus moi
je voudrais juste deux points très
précis concernant les
normes on nous dit tout le temps la
France lave plus blanc que blanc on est
toujours plus compliqué plus lourd que
les d'autres pays européens et du coup
on se crée nous-même une on se rend
moins concurrentiel par rapport à
d'autres pays et ça c'est sûr et certain
je l'ai vérifié dans mon département et
puis ensuite il a encore autre chose la
lecture des des normes des textes n'est
pas la même d'un département à l'autre
ça je pense qu'il y a quand même
un uniformiser les choses et ça c'est
valable pour pour l'agriculture mais
c'est valable pour tout hein je peux
vous donner des exemples pour la miante
et cetera je crois qu'il faut arriver en
France à avoir la même vision des choses
en Bretagne dans le Nord dans l'in dans
le sud c'est très important je pense
parce que c'est vécu comme une injustice
chez les
agriculteurs ça fait partie des sujets
je pense qu'on porte dans le cadre de la
de de tous les projets de simplification
bon il y a le choc de simplification il
y avait aussi la la modernisation de
l'action public et puis les États
généraux du droit de l'environnement
c'est moins à nous d' d'en parler parce
que c'est des choses qui sont menées par
Delphine bateau mais cette idée
harmonisation et de plus grande
lisibilité de au niveau de la règle ça
c'est quelque chose qui est qu'on a
qu'on a très clairement en tête qui nous
remonte aussi par nos services
déconcentrés donc il y a pas de il y a
c'est c'est un objectif partagé
euh juste quand même peut-être un mot
aussi s le contrôle de Bruno sur le côté
la France lave plus blanc que blanc je
crois que en fait tous les pays ont
l'impression que qu'on lave que qu' sont
plus dur que nous et et si et si on est
aujourd'hui où on en est sur la
directive nitrate faut quand même aussi
être clair sur le sujet si on en est à
un contentieux qui d alors que la
directive elle a 20 ans maintenant c'est
aussi parce qu'on a toujours traîné des
pieds pour l'appliquer et on est le seul
pays à être encore en contentieux sur le
sujet et donc c'est un sujet sur lequel
on a quand même été la plupart du temps
moins 10 ans que les autres et les
autres pays et si la Commission est dure
sur le sujet c'est aussi parce qu'elle a
d'autres pays qui la poussent en disant
les Français font une nous font une
sorte de dumping environnemental sur la
question des nitrates alors tout ça peut
se discquilibre avec les de PS socix
voilà alors bon évidemment quand on
commence à faire la liste mais c'est
vrai il faut pas non plus être enfin je
pense qu'il faut il faut être assez
prudent là-dessus parce que il y a des
sujets sur lesquels on est peut-être
plus plus strict que d'autres parce que
ça correspond à des attentes clair sur
la directive nitrate je pense qu'on a on
est dans une situation où on a vraiment
traîné et pour le coup on est moins
strict que d'autres il y a aussi
d'autres d'autres sujets type mise au
norme et cetera où on a on n'est pas
toujours non plus les premiers arrivés
les premiers de la classe et avoir forcé
le le plus de monde he sur la par
exemple la mise en norme sur les truc
gestantes on progresse bien on est on
est on n pas on n pas on est pas au top
non mais on n'est pas non plus déjà au
normes à on nétait pas à 100 % au
normees à la date de de mise en norme
faut être clair hein donc donc à un
moment il faut êre il faut aussi être
assez assez prudent là-dessus je veux
dire il y a il y a un moment où où il
faut voilà on peut pas non plus
sélectionner dans la liste des normes
qui s'appliquent celles sur lesquelles
on est plus dur en en regardant pas trop
celles sur lesquelles on n'est pas on
n'est pas complètement au point donc
voilà mais ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
pas essayer d'être toujours le de de
d'améliorer les choses sur un certain
nombre de normes enfin voilà je je juste
être assez clair là-dessus et c'est vrai
que là-dessus quand même je me
permettrais de de signaler que la
transposition des directive elle est
souvent quand même un peu plus renforcée
sur la France que dans les autres pays
donc je crois que si on peut simplifier
là aussi il faudra le faire hein parce
que j'ai moi j'ai eu multiples
exemplesou on a les mêmes exemples et on
en a conscience et et on cherche pas à
s'exonérer je dis pas ça pour qu'on en
disant on s'exonère de toute
simplification ou de toute réflexion sur
les normes et cetera il y a aucun
problème je dis juste que c'est que
c'est c'est un sujet sur lequel il faut
être assez prudent aussi vous avez
peut-être vu aussi les producteurs d'œuf
qui vous disent il y a des gens qui sont
pas au normes EN ITALIE sur les poules
pondeuses parce que nous on est au
normes nous on leur dit en même temps
porter ce sujet là alors que sur sur les
Tru gestantes on est en train de se
mettre en norme faut faire un peu
attention aussi donc faut voilà c'est
tout mais question
d'équilibre juste apporter un petit
complément s'agissant des normes
sanitaires et de application et de la
question que vous éoquz de
l'hétérogénéité d'appréciation locale
dire que c'est un souci permanent de la
direction générale d'alimentation et de
du ministre et qui vise notamment à
faire en sorte que l'on ait des
instructions qui permettent vraiment
d'homogéniser l'approche dans chacun des
départements au niveau des services
d'inspection et ça passe notamment par
une démarche d'accréditation des
services he les services vétérinaires
sont accrédités Surel une norme qui est
reconnue donc par le COFRAC pour les
organis inspection avec des instructions
qui sont unifiées qui sont en constante
évolution pour simplifier les choses
également pour la compréhension par les
opérateurs mais ça reste un sujet
vraiment de préoccupation extrêmement
important parce que au-delà même de
l'acte d'inspection c'est également
derrière un enjeu économique à travers
la certification que l'on peut faire des
produits vis l'exportation et qui
nécessite d'avoir ce ce souci de
l'homogénéité des inspections dans les
départements ce qui n'empêche que les
inspections sont réalisées par des
hommes et non des machines et donc il
peut toujours y avoir une marge
individuel d'appréciation mais que en
tout cas c'est un souci permanent de
d'homogénéiser les approches à les
instructions qui soi le plus clair
possible et que ça laisse moins de
possibilité à la
controverse en Bretagne on on nous a
expliqué
que c'est parce
que les agents dans les départements
sont responsables de leur décision que
du coup ils ont tendance à ouvrir des
parapluies et à durcir un peu la lecture
qu'ils font des textes
question ou trois petits points enfin
oui alors effectivement bien évidemment
à chaque fois qu'un opérateur se voit
notifier une nonconformité sous une
forme ou une autre qui peut prendre en
fonction de la gravité de la situation
relevée une demande simple d'action
corrective ou lorsqu'il y a une volonté
de fraude ce qui arrive hein on nous
n'avons pas des opérateurs qui sont tous
vertueux comme il devrait l'être des
actions qui sont engagées au pénal bien
évidemment ça ne plaît pas à l'opérateur
pour autant comme vous l'avez indiqué
l'agent exerce une responsabilité qui
est reconnue par le code pénal et que en
cas de non exercice de cette
responsabilité il peut être directement
mis en cause pour fait de négligence qui
pourrait entraîner également des
problème de santé publique donc
effectivement il y a une responsabilité
qui est claire et il y a des agents qui
ont déjà été condamnés pour ne pas avoir
vu ou ne pas vouloir
voir des des des des des écarts des
nonconformités qui peuvent générer un
problème de santé publique parce que
dans le domaine sanitaire c'est c'est
quand même bien ça l'enjeu qui est
derrière pour autant effectivement il y
a une gradation quand même dans dans la
la comment le l'approche qui doit être
faite et en général lorsque l'on a
lorsque l'on arrive à un procès verbal
qui est souvent la sanction qui est vécu
comme étant la plus lourde pour un
opérateur puisque après on s'en remet au
juges pour décider ou non de du niveau
de gravité de cette sanction c'est quand
même relativement rare ou alors il faut
vraiment qu'il y a une infraction très
importante caractériser immédiatement
queon soit dans la première étape et
quand on regarde les taux de que le le
procèsverbal soit la première étape qui
soit choisie par l'opérateur par
l'inspecteur au moment du la
constatation de de la nonconformité on a
un taux d'infraction et un taux de
procès verbaux qui est relativement
faible si on regarde l'ensemble du
secteur
agroalimentaire pour des questions
sanitaires j'entends et et en revanche
un taux de de notification
administrative de nonconformité de
demande d'action corrective qui est
beaucoup plus important donc on est
s'agissant des services étéridaires je
je parle pas vous avez d'autres services
qui interviennent sont les services des
fraudes qui ont d'autres moyens d'action
mais s'agissant des services
vétérinaires globalement le moyen
d'action qui est qui est qui est
recherché en priorité c'est de faire
cesser l'infraction et la le faire le
fait de faire cesser l'infraction c'est
l'action administrative donc c'est la
demande d'action corrective bien sur
après s'il y a refus d' enteré on passe
sur un autre registre qui qui peut
entraîner des actions
pénales voilà pour cette audition
d'expert par la mission commune
d'information sur la filière viande vous
pourrez évidemment la revoir à tout
instant sur notre site
publicsenat.fr très bonne journée à vous
sur notre
chaîne